e
good
morning it being 10 o'clock we're going
to start officially the uh presentations
for the capital budget uh leading off
today is uh Department of administrative
Services welcome to Public Works you're
up thanks for having us um I'm Charlie
Arling house I'm the commissioner of
administrative services and with me uh
Ted cupper is the director of Public
Works and Karen rcky is the director of
plant and property and part of our
presentation includes the beginning half
of it an overview of how we get here as
a state that is to say how the process
works for some of you who have been on
this committee since before I was born
maybe J Mike m Mike years ago we did
this and one of your colleagues was
really impatient with me for explaining
things and kept going like this to me
but he wasn't reelected
so so we're okay um so so I'm going to
start and actually Karen is going to
start and tell you who Das is and begin
the way the process works from the P
perspective of of an agency submitting
requests great
so my part of d the division of plant
and property um we're about half of the
staff um we maintain and operate 96
buildings throughout the state including
many Office Buildings so the
headquarters for many state agencies all
the cour houses um we don't maintain or
operate any Residential Properties so no
hospitals no prisons nothing like that
um we do maintain our buildings through
a combination of In-House staff and
contracted Services um it's kind of the
way we have to balance things um in
order to stay with budget and to try to
can great um so now I'll just talk a
little bit about um how we evaluate our
facilities and decide what ends up in
our capital budget request every bium um
so each
year my staff go through each of those
96 buildings they do a walkthr they fill
out information regarding the status of
every building system so the HVAC the
lighting uh the building envelope
including Windows um the
exterior um any Paving parking lots
things like that we document all of that
and then um we take all of that
information for all of the facilities
and kind of combine them and then do a
prioritization based on that so there
might be 30 buildings that need Paving
projects but we might select the top
five that need to be done for example um
this year we were able to do a
professional facility condition
assessment where we had a consultant
come in and evaluate every single one of
our um Central facilities buildings so
that's about half of that 96 um and that
was really helpful because they
documented the age of all of our systems
so when those boilers when those HVAC
systems were installed um when the
carpeting was last replaced all of those
things were documented and then from
there they projected out when they think
we will need to replace or work on those
systems um and that has kind of guided
us a little bit better and so we have a
few changes in our prioritizations from
where we were last year when we
submitted our original um capital budget
submission um included with our uh
prioritized list of capital project
requests we do a very rough uh kind of
guesstimate of how much we think it will
cost and that's very basic like a roof
might cost you know5 or $10 a square
foot and we multiply that out we just
say this is what we think the roof is
going to cost um Ted will talk a little
bit more about how those numbers get
refined later on in the
process um and then we complete the
comprehensive capital budget forms that
are required uh for each and every
project summarizing um over three Bia of
where where we think we're going to be
um with those Capital requests um and
that gets rolled up at the department
level and then sent over to the
governor's office for
consideration so that that's kind of a
snapshot of what agency does and and
what I want to emphasize is every agency
kind of does the same thing what Karen
does is much more comprehensive because
she has a big maintenance staff that
does it um an agency making a capital
budget request does the same thing
though they look at what their needs are
that are capital is and then they triage
and they decide well I can't ask for
everything and I'm going to pick my
priorities and and that becomes the
giant set of requests that is the
initial
basis of the governor's capital budget
hearing so these forms used to be called
form 1A and we're trying to streamline
it but it's still sort of form 1A but
these forms are all put together it is
what the agency wants to do not
necessarily what's a great idea to do um
in every detail it's what they they
think it will roughly cost and some
agencies will estimate that really well
and some won't because they don't have
that level of experience they're they're
not building stuff all the time so so
they don't know and on it projects
everybody basically gets the assistance
of doit to guess to guesstimate those
costs so there's a giant binder that's
produced for the Governor's capital
budget hearings and and some of some of
you attend a lot of you look online um
but it is basically every agency
presents to the governor and and you
basically can present anything you want
that you've done a form for and we do
three days of hearings and everybody
gets up Ted is on the panel I'm on the
panel Dennis gay from doit is on the
panel the governor's budget director
chairs the hearing and we're basically
talking to him and and it's a big binder
of stuff so that that's what that
hearing is about and there are
representatives of the of the house and
the Senate um typically the chairs of
Public Works are invited and um and some
people come and lately a lot of people
watch online so there are fewer people
in the audience than there used to be um
so so it's less of a big deal that set
of requests is enormous so typically the
general fund portion is about 700
million let's say and you're going to
fund about 120 million and so it it's
way too much nobody gets anything that
they want they get a little tiny
fraction of what they want but it's the
start of that process so if you turn to
prioritization typically in the past the
governor's office has asked uh has asked
us dasas and mostly Public Works to go
through and basically divide them into a
b and c the a are like obvious health
safety issues um and C would be
like a shower in a bathroom at a state
agency that's what we typically always
used to put last on the list and you
just prioritize that way why we do it
because the number of projects that are
formally estimated is better if it's
smaller because there's more time to go
into detail that that real estimate um
and so typically the governor's office
will
select maybe twice as many by dollar
value as they might fund two $300
million worth of projects for DPW to
estimate now what happens to be that
this year um they didn't do that they
they eliminated some before the hearing
and then basically um the governor's
budget director because he might not be
returning said just estimate all of them
which ends up being
more work but and less detail so the
estimates
are not quite as detailed as they might
have been if we had time to do more but
Ted's going to talk to you a little bit
about when we decide which projects are
estimated what Public Works does and how
that process works in in getting to in
getting to produce this book which we'll
talk about in a
minute good morning Ted CER the director
of uh the division of public works so uh
Public Works is a a group of about 22
people who all engineers and Architects
and we're tasked with um either building
new buildings for the state or
maintaining buildings that the state
already owns so we have a great deal of
expertise in estimating uh capital
projects so as uh Charle and Karen uh
just explained uh these estimates um
come from the governor office and we
asked to uh prepare a detailed estimate
each one of our project managers or
contract administrators as they're
sometimes called um takes on seven to 10
of these
estimates and uh and they dive deeply
into them uh they pull archive plans uh
they meet with the agencies they go
visit each and every site uh sometimes
uh there's photographs involved they
take measurements and then they come
back to the office and using several
different
resources um determine how much that
project costs they also include um
overhead and
profit um uh consultant fees that might
be involved in the cost of the project
um our fees which by law were required
to um uh to ask for and uh and then we
put together these
estimates and um and
ultimately by law the estimates have to
be produced by December 1st and that's
what this book is here and nobody gets
to see this book until the governor
makes uh their uh budget presentation
sometime in you know
mid-February and and this becomes part
of the budgets the overall Governor's
budget that's good um
so at this stage we're well into the
process right agencies have started
looking at buildings maybe in January or
February it's it's almost a year later
this book is produced there are a couple
things about this book so first of all
you're not limited to so you're not
limited to what the governor proposed
you're not limited to what agencies want
you can have your own ideas you're not
technically limited to what's in this
book although typically it's unusual
when something comes outside of the book
um in
2017 the governor proposed funding a
project that was not in the CIP book and
it was because I was his budget director
and um there was a the we said some the
state librarian was the was the acting
director Commissioner of cultural
resources and he's like I don't want an
archaeological thing I want a union
catalog and I'm like okay and so we did
that we he was very helpful and we gave
him something he wanted um but every
project has a narrative and and I say
that because it it does two things one
it helps you understand the project it's
a much more detailed it's a really good
synopsis but secondly when you pass a
project this
becomes legislative intent and we look
at it um later in the process like if an
agency wants to take the capital money
um when you're building building or
fixing a building you often change what
you're doing
they're not permitted to change to
deviate from the purpose of what this is
because this is thought to be what you
approved this is this is thought to be
what you are saying yes to so uh
famously I think four years ago HHS
wanted to do windows instead of doors I
think it was maybe it was doors instead
of
Windows and and somebody said to them
and I'm not going to tell you who it is
but his name is Chris and um but
somebody said to them door is not a
window and you need to get legislation
and so and it's because the item was
very specific to it wasn't openings as
you see fit to make the building safe it
was you want to do windows for this
purpose you change your mind and you
want to do doors for a different purpose
he's like well that's not what they
approved and so so that's why this book
is also very important because it's
binding um it it's it is a description
of legislative intent
um so the governor will present a budget
presentation um but every agency
understands that where the rubber really
hits the road I mean not that we don't
all do exactly what the governor tells
us to every day every moment and I would
like that on the record um the um but um
house Public Works is what matters I I
remember eight years ago I said to
Governor
sonunu um he had a couple of ideas for
the capital budget and I said at the end
of the day we're just going to do
whatever Jean Chandler wants so why
don't we just start by asking him if
this is okay and
um that was literally true he we got
everything je Chandler was okay with and
there were a couple things he didn't
like and they didn't make it um that was
then this is now it's a very different
regime Mr chairman but I'm sure um just
just tell the governor that I don't
spell my name that way you give give her
a different spelling in case case
there's any beefs about this that's what
I'll
do um so what I want to do now is talk
about our budget and we're going to end
with Karen talking about lapses and and
the items we don't want to lapse but um
I'm going to tell you what is included
and what we would like you to consider
also including so the governor's office
funded 1.5 million um this is slide 14
actually uh 1.5 million for the
emergency fund which we which is
something we fund every year um the
annex is being renovated if you've been
in the annex lately it's it's kind of a
mess um I mean not my office obviously
but the rest of it is kind of a mess um
but good things are happening every time
I hear an anvil drop on the floor over
my head and think it's going to come
through I say I bet that's progress and
the floor will hold so far it has um but
the second half of that project is is
12.5 million 12.25 million and so that's
in here there's a sprinkler replacement
at DMV for 500 50,000 they funded and
the elevator at the main building the
main building being the oldest building
on the on the State Hospital campus the
big building where Corrections used to
be and isn't anymore and HHS is in a
bunch of the Wings it's that building
and the
elevator really bad and it breaks
constantly um more so than the other
state elevators which break a lot this
one breaks constantly so that that's
that now um we did a nice chart Karen
did the slides by the way I'm going to
take credit for them but you'll you'll
know that she actually did them so if
they look nice it's it's because of her
and um if you really like them though
you could give me credit cuz I asked her
to do them so I should get some credit
for that um so historically we um this
is how much money has been allocated to
das projects and recent Capital budgets
and I do this because it's a lot less
less this year than it has been in the
past and and even though the total
amount the governor is proposing to fund
is higher than it has I think been
ever ever
um and and that's to
say if it were me and I knew the
condition state buildings were in I'd
spend a little bit more money on fixing
up state buildings um and I'm going to
tell you the the two things that I want
to ask you to do um but but I but I say
this to say we're not asking for a
greater share the pie than we think we
should get but we're asking we're hoping
that you might think about at least
among your competing interests bringing
us up to sort of historic levels for
what we do um Karen's going to talk
about the the project she and her team
went through in in a triage to come up
with but before she does that I'm going
to skip ahead of slide to slide 17 and
talk about the Erp system the basic
computer system I actually have the the
entire piece from the CIP book here um
because it's a complicated system and I
wanted you to have it for your records
but the Erp system is a computer system
that runs the state it it runs payroll
it runs HR it runs finances it runs the
budget it runs everything supply chain
Etc we are we are upgrading it we're
going through a massive upgrade to take
it to the cloud and the most significant
um redo of the system since 2009 um when
we first went live with what was then
Lawson and is now in for it's called New
Hampshire first but it is an Erp it is
the enterprise
system um historically we um it has been
important to have a fund for
sustainability and advancement which
means upgrading it modernizing it adding
modules that you need as they become
available so that you can uh you can put
them into the system it is particularly
important this year because of a because
we're upgrading and one of the things
that happens in a project that will
eventually kill half of my staff
probably or at least give them all
stress related time off
um you find things you discover things
and and computers are ridiculously
expensive now that's just the way it is
but what we would ask you to look at is
um as we find synergies and
opportunities and I identify one that
works for Treasury and and things
related to it um like uh cash management
and bank reconciliation
um it's important for us over the course
of the two years to be able to tap into
that and we ask for about $5 million for
that and I'd like you to if you would
consider that it it it is of critical
importance to running that system um and
and it's something that committee has
looked favorably on before I'm going to
ask Karen to talk to you about five
particular um maintenance type projects
that she has
identified great thank you um so as
Charlie mentioned mened um in the
previous slide um the projects included
in the governor's version of the capital
budget were a lot less than in the past
um and a particular note there were no
projects included for the Bureau of
Court facilities so we maintain um all
of the 21 state-owned cour houses in the
state as and we also um enter into
leases for the remaining ones but um the
ones that we own you know have needs
like the rest of our buildings do and I
realize that the the top request of the
judicial branch was for the new Sullivan
County Courthouse which is a lot um but
if that cannot be funded there of course
additional maintenance projects that we
would love to have funded so I've listed
the top two prioritized projects here
which is um HVAC um maintenance for the
Portsmouth circuit court and the Coos
County courthouse at 4.3 million is the
DPW estimate on that one um and the
second one is boilers and controls for
Carol County and Lebanon circuit court
for 2.85
million
um additionally I mentioned earlier that
we did a a thorough facility condition
assessment and because of that we moved
around our priorities a little bit we
realized that our main building um
exterior brick as well as the annex
which is the building right next to it
um is deteriorating and so we're
requesting 600,000 to repoint the brick
on that facility um over the last you
know eight or so or 10 years we've been
slowly replacing windows of all of those
older buildings over on the hospital
campus Spalding is one that we haven't
done yet which is in dire need of um
some new windows um so that's a $1.6
million request there and then as
Charlie mentioned earlier our elevators
specifically on that campus I think just
particularly due to the age of the
buildings and how long elevators have
been uh in there um our Brown building
elevators also need in need of
replacement so that's um a
um happy to answer questions on any of
that unless you would like us to first
talk about the
lapses um why don't you go ahead and
talk about the lapses and then we'll
come back and we'll ask questions for
that well I might have questions on the
lapses
also Karen's going to talk about lapses
because I don't know anything
about um and again I won't go through
detail on every single one but if you
have questions on any particular ular
one I will be more than happy to answer
those questions I have some notes with
me um and she's going to talk from the
list that's in the back of
this yes page
seven um so starting at the bottom of
page seven these are in order of the
newest projects first um and we'll go on
first eight projects were approved in
the last
bium can I just interrupt for a second
just so if the members don't have the
pink book you've got a spreadsheet that
I dropped on your in front of you you
along thank you okay so the first eight
projects approved um in
2023 um those are all currently under
construction um so we're asking to
extend all of those um the next chunk of
projects from 2021 there's a lot um and
the reason there's so many from
2021 um is because that's when the AR
arpa money came available and I think a
lot of projects were moved out of the
capital budget to arpa funds and then
there was room in the capital budget for
additional projects and so we have a lot
of projects um from 2021 additionally I
think Public Works resources has been
very busy with arpa projects and so some
of these are taking longer than they
normally would have because the arpa has
become a priority d to the funds lapsing
at the end of calendar 26 I will just to
to add to that in terms of construction
generally we're not going to get any
anything you approv done in two years we
we might
accidentally a simple project but but
there is U because of arpa because of um
construction demand because of a
Slowdown during the covid years there is
a sort of a backlog and so what Ted's
team does is they do the next project
next and then the next one next and the
next one next and so you'll notice this
will be a theme that there are just a
ton of projects that are taking um from
passage of the capital budget to
completion of the project four to six
years not not two to
three there um there is one project in
the 2021 list it's um for the Hillsboro
Cooling and control so I'm going to try
um if you would could you just clarify
uh I think you stated down to number
eight was uh current projects that are u
under construction now um and then these
2021s they go to what number on the list
just help me make sure I know where I am
on yep so
202 is it 32 I just want to make sure
and then there's a
different
okay thank you
too do you want to use the the this is
what I have yeah let see here so parents
going to switch and use the house bill
25 list because they're number as
opposed to the government's budget if
that's easier for
you yeah yes okay um you're using a
worksheet that that Chris put out I
don't have
that oh okay right either way let's do
um Okay so were're talking about the
2021 projects that go through number
32 um there's one project that's
obviously not on the list because we
already indicated that it would lapse
and that was for the Hillsboro Cooling
and controls project um moving down to
projects
um again most a lot of these are still
under construction we do have a handful
that are complete and we have a a
request that we're will be submitting to
Capital project overview to re reassign
some of those funds to a project that's
not complete which is the Hillsboro
County um South cell block renovation
which was also approved in 2019 but has
not yet started and is um quite
considerably underfunded according to
the number that was
appropriated um in 20 the 20 17 projects
at number
um we do have an additional project that
we have reviewed and is complete and we
will be lapsing and that's uh the
Rochester Court project and that
here no I'm sorry that's the Spalding
roof project number 49
um so that is complete and we will be
lapsing the remainder of those
funds that's number 49 is going to lapse
yes okay thank
you um and the last I checked which I
believe was late last week there was
$81,000 remaining in that
appropriation um the Rochester Court
project um boiler project had already we
had already indicated that that would be
lapsing
um starting at 54 there's um one project
from
2015 um which we have some just small
amount of flooring that we're uh
finishing up at the Apple marker house
so that will be completed fairly quickly
um but we won't be lapsing that and then
um the final project Charlie is number
55 and I think you were going to speak
to that
one it's a small amount of money
remaining that is for uh that we're
using as part of the the upgrade to the
Erp system
and so we're we're not going to we're
not going to lapse it in fact that's why
I'm asking you for more money and so
um we're go live is tentatively expected
by uh in early 2026 and at that point
that will be done but it won't be done
by July and
so so I'm afraid I I hope you won't
lapse
it representative Jack any questions uh
thank you um just to clarify um
in from 2019 2b2 state house spacement
lapse number what number is that on uh
it's not a number because it's not in
House Bill 25 so it would lapse I want
to confirm that they want to lapse that
it's state house basement fire
protection from 2019 yeah that project
is done it's actually not showing up on
my list which probably means there's no
money and then there was that you wanted
to repurpose through capital budget
overview and I didn't catch yeah so
there's actually a few projects from
2019 um I can list them if you'd like um
it includes Court Courthouse
generators um a new boiler at Coos
County Courthouse um Cooling and
controls at uh Rockingham and Hillsboro
County Courthouse
um various buildings that had roof
Replacements Andor exterior repairs and
the State House Annex elevator and
there's little amounts in all of those
like mostly 15,000 25,000 and we'd like
to T take all of that and put it towards
the Hillsboro County South uh cell block
project if possible that's something we
can do in House Bill 25 if you want to
way and I think we were looking at doing
it through um capital budget
overview because it would happen faster
and
we're timing matter and and that's
allowable um action of the capital
project overview committee as long as
it's in the same uh capital budget that
they're moving the same type of money to
another
project and we've done this before with
the Department in that
committee thanks thank you
okay Senator Brown thank you Mr chairman
just a general question here so on these
recommendations do they typically have a
remaining schedule or expectancy and
what is still outstanding on that budget
item for the lapsed items I'm not
looking for it now but I'm just yeah I
would say for the most part I mean that
Hillsboro County cell block I think is
just starting design um but that's an
anomaly most of these are either like in
design Design's been completed they're
either out to bid or somewhere in
construction so it's not like they're
we're waiting on them it's just as
Charlie was mentioned things are taking
four to six years instead of two to
three years just because of the backlog
of projects but gu my question chairman
um do they have a a projected schedule
and projected dollar amount by year how
do how do you guys do that yeah so we we
we have a schedule or an expected
completion date um if they haven't bid
yet then it would be hard to say like
what the the price is going to come in
at but if it has been bid then we
definitely have a a cost and usually
that's encumbered at the time that it's
approved by governor and Council so we
know exactly how much is remaining in
that account thank you thank you Mr
chairman okay representative
Jack uh well actually represent boget
was first but just to confirm so the one
action we're going to take is the lapse
number 49 with 81,000
remaining representative
buer yes thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question you had some
laps in here uh using arpa money and is
there plans in place to complete those
jobs or is there alternative plans if
you can't complete those jobs for
funding for those projects
because my assumption is the money
disappears at the end so that's a drop
dead date
so so all of our arpa projects are
scheduled to be completed prior to the
December 26th uh drop dead date um some
of them are creeping into fall of 26 all
of them are fully funded at this point
in terms of Money's been encumbered
contracts have been signed um if there
becomes a situation where we find
something unexpected
there really is no other place to pull
pull money from as you know so we're
just we're doing as much as we can under
the current contract and the current
funding that we have to complete those
projects thank
you uh I will ask a question then and
this goes
back only because representative Karen
eel isn't on his committee anymore so
I'll go ahead and ask her question um
give us an overview once again on on
where we draw the line why you are
requesting on your little wish list for
the uh uh Erp system why that isn't
under doit why where does
Do's Authority stop or begin no it's a
it's a really good question I mean
technically every IT project is done in
consultation with and requires the
approval of
doit um agencies who are producing a
like a like I think justice has a case
management system which they will run
and operate they need Do's permission
for the purchase for the to decide what
it is how they're going to use it but
they'll manage the project the generally
it is centralized it with one exception
and that one exception is the state's
Erp system the financial human resource
system is run by my department by the
division of Enterprise application
management deem and it is the single
biggest area of state government that is
not directly under doit yet is it and so
that's that's the one exception why is
it our request though it's because we're
managing the project our or in fact
Cassie is managing the project um and um
but we have to do it in consultation
with um with Dennis goule and and so
everything we do he has to sign off on
thank you that's sort the general
clarification because I I I didn't go
through every line so far in our little
pink book
but in the past we've had new for
instance in this in this case if if it
was a Judicial System it would even
though it was a
doit item it would come under the
judicial budget it would come out of
their money so it's sort of like Mr
chairman if you think about it this way
you're we're going to do a bunch of
building projects where there will there
will be a contract for the building for
um like fishing game for example
there'll be a contract for the building
between my department and the contractor
it'll be managed by the division of
Public Works which is in my department
yet the funds are being appropriated to
fishing game and so it's just because
it's
their build when it's done they'll
manage it thank you any other questions
here representative okay thank you Mr
chairman a question of General about the
under administrative Services Bureau of
Court facilities uh I noticed you're I
think you're me asking for some projects
repair projects the
ahac but I'm wondering is there a list
and I've seen this list before of court
houses all around the state are on the
priority list to be either renovated or
completely constructed and the reason I
asked is obviously in the brown book
that Sullivan County has a request that
is in the brown book and I know probably
it's not in this budget but is is a
possibility and I ask this on behalf of
my County manager who is in the same bus
building among others but if you have
such a list could you share it with this
the rest of this committee because some
of us may be interested in where our
cour houses stand yeah annually we do a
uh with the court system there's a
process called the court accreditation
committee and then they produce a
document which happened to be finalized
last week um I I got mine in I got a
electronic version and mine came in the
mail yesterday um so I can get you that
copy which is a multi-year plan in
addition to that if you want to look at
um to get a sense if you look in our
administrative Services
list and you look at the Grid in the in
the CIP book and you look at the grid
um this this order is roughly um
although it's mixing all of our projects
it's not just courts but the court the
order of them is roughly the priority
order so you you'll see
the the sixth project is a $34 million
Courthouse sixth Pro and that's not
their sixth project that's our sixth
project um but I'll get you a copy of
the Court Prior the official document
that they publish um and I'll send that
to Mr Shay
um
today okay thank you follow thank you Mr
share I know I will be interested and
thank you for so giving us that
information thank you by the way we're
if you decide
that you agree that Sullivan County
needs a new courthouse and you want to
spend 34 million on that instead of 4
million on HVAC we won't won't
object I wouldn't be holding my breath
about that but we'll take it under
consideration representative Newman you
had a
question yes thank you do any of the
guest toits estimates that you have done
up to this point I'm I'm sensitive to
say this here I don't know any other way
to say it do the new tariffs that are
coming into play have any effect or
anticipated effect on materials supplies
in you want to to go first that yeah uh
the short answer is no uh we were
anticipating tariffs uh coming in
although I I will say that we have some
projects that are out to bid and uh
awaiting governor and Council approval
and we're hearing from those
contractors uh questions what what if by
the time we get uh notice to proceed uh
after governor and Council approval what
what will happen to those projects that
we're experiencing tariffs with and we
don't have an answer for that right
yet thank you we're doing a lot of work
as a as in department on the purchasing
side and the construction side to try to
get a handle on that but until we know
what tariff is on what um I will say
that we uh the legislature passed a law
a year ago requiring American Steel on
projects of more than a
million so that already factors in
somewhat I mean leaving aside that
American seal might go up because
there's tariff protection too but
um we we won't really know until we know
a lot more about what tariffs look like
and and I think and particularly how
they relate to Canada right
Lan representative jurus thank you Mr
chairman a lot of a lot of projects seem
to be uh in the you know estimated in
the process for uh upgrading
HVAC uh and
boilers uh is there any in any of these
efforts are we considering heat pumps
are we considering solar hot water to
help with the boilers uh roofs are we
considering when we do a roof maybe
possibly adding affable Vol TS yes so um
HVAC is tricky we did a lot of HVAC with
arpa a lot of our HVAC systems are past
their useful life and a lot of our
buildings still don't have HVAC so it's
continuously going to be a high priority
of request on our Capital list um we are
doing some heat pumps um the annex
renovation has a little bit of um of
that um we're trying to use them where
appropriate um we've done a few solar PV
systems in recent years that we do most
of that happens through our energy
saving performance contract program
which is separate than this Capital
process um solar hot water we did a
little bit I don't know 10ish 15 years
ago I feel like it hasn't been I feel
like the PV has kind of taken off and
become more efficient and the hot water
maybe isn't as as popular anymore as it
was um so we do look at all those things
in addition um there's a requirement to
look at a renewable energy component for
all large capital projects so we review
that and where it's cost effective we're
adding those
in thank you any other qu any other
questions representative
bogert thank you uh thank you Mr
chairman um the question I have goes
back to DPW section um in there you
mentioned U
uh that you charge a fee for your
services for contracts so list take
hypothetically the uh U uh fishing game
where you're going to do a project for a
building hypothetically they're going to
pay for the building and you'reall going
to manage the project and y'all charge a
fee for that service right so
uh um our involvement with the project
starts when uh the using agency who's
been appropriated the money submits a
work request
West and some of those projects are
capital projects some of those projects
are what we call maintenance projects
they're you using their operating budget
to do those projects so a work request
comes to us and we assign that
particular project to a project manager
an engineer or an architect that has
experience in that kind of work that
kind of building
work um that project
manager uh employs an outside consultant
to help us with the design so now our
project manager is managing an outside
consultant and coordinating between the
design work from the outside consultant
and the using agency so let's say liquor
wants to build a new liquor store right
um liquor knows how to sell booze um but
they don't know that much about building
building
so but they know what they they know
what it want they want it to look like
they know how they want the product
displayed they know how they want their
parking lot to interface with their
entrance and where the cash registers
are so they have this vision of what the
building is going to look like and we're
the middleman transferring that Vision
to the consultant so we can have
construction documents that we can put
out to bid
once the project the design project is
complete those project managers then
package that up into bid documents put
it out to bid evaluate the
bids um choose the low
bidder and then package it up uh to go
to governor and counsel once governor
and Council approves the project we can
issue a notice to proceed to that low
bid contractor who was awarded the
project and now the project manager at
DPW manages the construction project to
make sure that that building for liquor
is built according to the plans and
specifications that were designed by the
consultant it's a lot of work um and by
law uh we're required uh to charge using
agencies a fee for the work that we do
on their
projects and those fees are included in
our capital budget estimates as well
follow up when if I can to clarify
something about on a budgeting
standpoint this is I think 21 I 82 but
somewhere in our statute and when Public
Works was set up the decision was or the
thought was for generally funded things
we're using general funds but for
Federal fund projects and Highway fund
projects and other fund projects we want
to take advantage of those funds so
we're we're not we're legally required
to charge and then the idea is is to
recoup um non-general fund share that
way in addition to that um in recent
years capital projects have been added
to that and and it's a way of not using
general funds more than um the state has
to in certain ways to maximize other
funds like you have the ent ent General
as 100% federally funded project or
we're going to charge for that to recoup
the cost of running um a division of
Public Works and um and and I think it
was about 12 14 years ago when Senator
Morris was then Senator Morris was on
the capital budget committee and the
Senate that language was uh basically
mandating that we also have clerks and
that they be paid out of capital funds
on that which is why there's a there's
typically a footnote in the capital
budget to that effect follow just one
followup with that I'm going to break
this to see if I understand it down to
layman's term a little bit the fees you
charge offset the cost of running your
department which is charged against the
general
fund yes yeah that's good simplistic
right that's much better than I did and
and the fees the fees the fees don't
cover our entire operating budget just
offsets correct thank
you any other
questions representative
boy thank you Mr chairman thank you for
commissioner for making my taking my
question regarding the uh
erps $5 million to modernize the entire
system buys us an additional 10 years is
that how I'm reading the narrative in
the perspectus it it's actually more
like 20 this five is is extra and and we
get we get at least 10 years out of it
but the the project is ongoing right now
with um a $12 million contract with with
in4 a separate contract with a company
called axum which is an implementer uh
an ivnv contract with a with another
company and and this is this is an
addition to that but um we will yeah we
get another 10 years at least out of the
out of the
system but like every computer system we
have to upgrade it over time because if
you don't there you end up like a lot of
State systems there's two 80-year old
men who the only people left who know
how to run it and they both want to move
to Florida that's actually a actual case
of a system that we have today I think
they're 82 and
78 um quick pivot only go I I probably
didn't ask this question two years ago
but now I it's going to be a newbie
question in my third term but what is
the purpose of the Statewide emergency
fund and what's the current balance of
it um I'll get the current balance in a
minute but the Statewide emergency fund
we have we have an enormous deductible
on our buildings and and the idea is
that
um I think everybody knows this that our
state buildings are not in great shape
um I don't want to say they're they're a
dump but roofs leak pipes are bursting
infastructure I I get a text from Karen
at least once a week saying just FYI the
X in this building is down and we don't
know why but we're figuring it out I'll
get back to you in an hour and um and uh
are deductible on on insurance policies
it is a million on every
building uh just doing a quick um look
here because what we do get this
appropriated every bium it's been lately
one to1 and A5 million dollar per every
two years um there are currently little
bits remaining in the older accounts um
and by little Min bits I mean like
36,000 in one there's 4,000 in another
one um so if you add up the four open
accounts it's just over one and a half
million that's left um and I do always
like to add too that we have a a
building insurance policy for our larger
buildings for catastrophic events with a
$1 million deductible and so if we were
to have a catastrophic event we would
use at least a million dollars of that
to kind of go towards the replacement of
that building cost so we like to have at
least that much kind of in the in the
kitty so to speak just a quick quick
followup to so just in simplistic terms
it's kind of like having a capital
reserve fund municipalities have capital
reserve funds it's kind of your capital
reserve for those you know emergencies
as as you've titled it so correct and
I'll just clarify that every agency that
owns State Property is allowed to
request funds from that and so we've
supported Department of Corrections
we've supported the Liquor Commission
we've supported um dncr in you know when
they have an event um that they aren't
able to cover with their with their
regular operating budget okay thank
you further questions representative jur
thank you Mr chairman we Das and Public
Work let lets a lot of contracts and you
mentioned the choosing the lowest bidder
is that the lowest most responsible
bidder or is it usually just the lowest
bidder it's so it's
um it's it's the lowest bidder but a
typical project is Bid through the do
contracts office and do and Public Works
used to be in the same department and
since 2005 they aren't but the contracts
office wasn't split it's there um there
are biders that are pre-qualified for
certain kinds of projects and can be un
pre-qualified if things don't go well um
which doesn't happen a lot but it does
happen and so the the project is we
typically use a design bid build method
where the plans are the plans it's not
it's not that flexible and and it's very
very um precise and um there are
requirements you have to meet to be able
to bid but once you do if you're low
you're low we have a public bid opening
and and the and everybody sort of gets
it in the load bid ons we've had very
few problems from that um we in large
part because we manage and it's why we
have a public works but we've famously
have had a few and uh there was a the
Regional training facility at at the
guard uh about 10 12 years ago um was a
cataclysmic failure and um cost the
state millions of dollars and insurance
companies millions of dollars but um bad
company but we don't we think we know
who the bad companies are and they don't
get to
bid thank
you any further questions Mr chair
represent restive cludia okay thank you
Mr chair commissioner Arling house and I
think I asked you this question two
years ago in a similar capital budget
hearings as far as electric vehicles I'm
sure some of the employees and
contractors who work at state agencies
have electric or hybrid vehicles which
any either way have you built some
charging stations or facilities for
those vehicles uh you know obviously
certain percentage maybe 10 20% and I
mean I don't seem to see it maybe such a
minuscule expense but I'm just curious
about I sometimes get questions from
reps outside this committee uh who are
curious about that we we have there
there's no State policy right now on on
whether you do or don't but we have um I
know it was looked at for the parking
garage that's going
up wherever it is over there yeah there
um and I don't remember if it made it
into or not because we did whatever the
legislator was told us to do um we had
built charging uh char stations behind
the boiler house over here um recently
and and in some other projects I can't
think of other ones off hand maybe I can
just add I I know Environmental Services
has
um uh EVS in their Fleet and so they
they have some charging stations at
their headquarters we found that the
best model honestly in my opinion is
that um the charging station is owned by
the like a charge point or a company
that does that and then they manage you
know the the finances and all those
pieces and they just get to put it on
our property and reimburse us for the
electricity they use um which means we
don't have to put out any Capital funds
to install
them thank you very much thank you Mr
chairman are questions yes
representative Jack uh thank you seeing
us we have a couple minutes uh can you
uh refresh my memory education has an
item number 73 about bathrooms and if I
remember correctly that's the building
they're not in anymore so is that is
there oh in uh the laps item yes
yes I'm trying to think what are we
doing on the I mean I know we're okay
you want to talk about
laan okay so laan Hall which is the
former headquarters for the New
Hampshire education uh Department um
they moved out and we dis purchased the
building at Hall Street where they are
now so that is now their headquarters um
because the laan hall was empty during
when arpa funds were distributed we
requested arpa funds to fully renovate
that building so it's gutted um it it's
slated to be completed September October
of this year um we've rolled the funding
for the bathrooms the capital funding
that was appropriated for the bathrooms
into that arpa project so the bathrooms
project any other further
questions seeing n thank you very much
you next up we have the department of
Information Technology if they're here
we can start them a couple of minutes
earlier
ah don't know why they didn't let them
in
let
this
good morning gentlemen welcome to Public
Works morning good morning Mr chair go
right ahead all right good morning Mr
chair members of the committee uh my
name is Dennis goule I am the
commissioner for the Department of
Information Technology and with me today
is Deputy Commissioner Ken Dunn
I would like to just let you know um
Chris Shay uh emailed out the
presentation last night and there was a
small error in it so the one you have
now is corrected and we'll get out a
corrected one to you um essentially it
was the second line in on page two that
was incorrect so we'll cover that um so
so I'll jump right into it uh looking at
page two um these are the what we
perceive as the Technology based capital
projects that are were funded in in the
governor's budget and uh so we looked at
them a couple different ways um for
appropriateness sake one is um what
priority was the project in the agency's
um request list so you can see that um
pretty appropriate except for ours and
I'll I'll cover that uh we only had
three and the priority three was
funded um but if you look at the other
ones there you know they were either the
first or the third and in the case of
HHS um they're pretty important those
are among the three largest and most
important systems in the state that
being the Medicaid and the eligibility
systems so so the um you know in terms
of the question as to whether you know
the uh the appropriate projects were
funded we think that in most cases that
is is correct um so moving on to page
three I will take you through uh what we
what our request was we really had three
three projects we requested one was
cyber
security um it service management phase
two phase one was funded in in the
current bium and then Cloud Solutions
and services and um so you can see our
priority three is funded in the
governor's budget and um we'd like to
ask that that be adjusted um we've the
cyber security challenges for all
organizations and state governments no
different um continue to change and
evolve and get more
complicated um with the benefit of
Appropriations in the last most recent
Bia we've been able to just keep up with
the challenges of protecting the state's
data and and now our continuity of
government in the past early days cyber
it was protecting data which of course
is important the privacy of Citizen data
but now with the Advent of ransomware
continuity of government is really an
issue as well so we're working hard on
that and we think it appropriate that um
if nothing else got funded this that the
cyber security uh Capital be funded so
our request would be to fully fund cyber
security enhancements and to reduce
cloud services down to $850,000 that
will get us part of the way down the
road for what we had planned and um
continue that moving along and and then
remove it service management phase two
why are we asking for that well in in
the context of other reductions that
we've made in our operating budget we we
decided to slow that program down so
that you know that would help us make
some savings on the operation Operation
budget side so we thought it appropriate
that that priority to be removed at this
time so so I'll pause there for a second
before before we move on to um the
explanations of the projects themselves
just in case there are any questions
right there any questions yes represent
below thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question so on the
area of cyber security can you sort of
give us
some I don't I guess data I mean how I
mean how severe is the need I mean and
how can you sort of demonstrate that
need well if we if we look at um the
the um State as a whole in our Ci's
towns and K through 12 it's almost every
week we're seeing a a city or a town or
a k through 12 being either ransomed or
having money stolen from them and it's
been very impactful throughout the state
um we haven't had that happen in the
executive branch during my tenure we've
had a couple breaches that we've managed
one early in days which was a Health and
Human Services data breach um but but
literally um we have um about
82% of all of our emails are not being
delivered to an inbox now because they
have some sort of um malware or um you
know bad actor
attempts um we're seeing very regular um
attempts to infiltrate our Network in
fact the protections we have on end
points um right now have um stopped at
least three three significant major
ransomware attempts in the last couple
of years and and if just to remind that
the committee ransomware is is
exceptionally bad you you know those
organizations you're seeing that just
complete completely fall off the map and
stop being able to do business that is
the result of ransomware what the what
the Bad actors do now is they'll they
will if they can get into one system it
used to be they'd get into one or two
systems and they would Ransom that
system and try to collect a little money
money now what they do is they will
they'll be patient particularly if it's
a large organization where they can feel
like they can extract money they will
get into a system and they will work
what they call horizontally which is
moving to other systems and get as many
systems as they can and get to your
backups if they can which is an
important note is you know we're working
one of the projects we're working on now
is to to update our backup system so
that we're sure that we have you know a
separation between the actual data and
the
backups once they've infiltrated a bunch
of systems then they will extract as
much data as they can so that even if
you have backups they will have caused a
data breach as part of that then they'll
hit the button and take all your systems
out and start communicating with you and
and try to extort money from you so it's
a real risk you're seeing it happen all
over the country we we're seeing it
happen inside the state of New Hampshire
and we're doing our best to protect it
followup thanks again thank you for that
answer so you mentioned something about
uh in the state so are you so how does
how do you work with uh local towns and
school districts and so on is is this
part of is this in your budget to do
that no um this is this money is just
for the um the executive branch um but
what we do we do have two other funding
sources that um we that are um Grant
related um one is historical which is we
get we typically uh get a small chunk of
the homeland security Grant monies
through the department of safety and uh
we we sit on that evaluation committee
for those grants and and we'll get a a
piece of that we've historically moved
uh used that money to provide services
for cities towns and K through 12 and
I'll explain that a little further once
I talk about the second funding source
there's a as part of the infrastructure
bill that was passed by the federal
government there was a piece of that is
a billion dollars for all the states
called the state and local cyber grant
program and so basically New Hampshire I
think was originally allocated around
14.6 over four years we had a whole
bunch of Hoops we had to jump through to
access those funds but we did
successfully jump through those Hoops in
fact New Hampshire was the very first
state to get year one approved approval
which we're proud of and we've been
using that money as well and we we have
a number of programs that we we have a
public private partnership you you may
be aware that uh
primex has the um you know creates uh uh
has the risk pool for most of the Cities
towns and K through 12s in New Hampshire
so what we do is we make sure that
whatever Prim X's programs are we're
doing something complimentary vice versa
so if primex is training for example
their customers in a certain area uh
they're insured in a certain area then
we're making sure we don't duplicate
that effort so we're kind of partnering
up to make sure that the total effort
between us and and and they and and in
Hampshire Municipal Association we get
feedback from them on what's needed and
how to best approach these
municipalities so those monies those two
pots of monies were effectively um
moving out through programs not through
subg grants because what we found is
these cities and towns don't have the
wherewithal to figure out what to do
with that money if if we had it also we
wouldn't they wouldn't have the
economies of scale we're able to get if
we're buying something for the entire
State we we can get the economies of
scale for that as well so it's really
two separate programs uh the other thing
we do is we partner closely with our
other branches of government including
the general court and our constitutional
offices to um coordinate cyber effort
for this for the state
government hope that
helps representative
jurus thank you Mr chairman so you
originally the security enhan cyber
security enhancements were denied but
we're going to make that adjustment by
deferring pushing off the it management
phase
tool make sure I mean what what I would
ask is is that we
we we eliminate itm service management
phase two we fully fund cyber security
and we partially fund Cloud Solutions
and services thank you I respectfully
request that thank
you representative Brown thank you Mr
chairman so you talked about the
coordinated efforts against the schools
and everything else in the state is
there an active program with the uh with
the counties to make sure because I know
for instance the sheriff's departments
and all those have
direct interaction with the AG and and
all that so I'm trying to figure out how
how does that work because I know we're
working in our County on upgrading our
systems too it's a really good point sir
um the we'll work with whoever will work
with us and that does include um you
know a number of law enforcement
entities around around the state as well
as because like a city is not always one
entity it varies a lot so you know in a
in a we may end up working with the the
the city um it folks or the city
government and then we were in that same
city we might be separately working with
law enforcement or or police and fire
you know so it it it varies depending on
the entity but so things we're doing is
training both Technical Training for the
professionals who are there inside the K
through 12s and the technical
professionals but also cyber awareness
training that's targeted to those
individuals so that um and that's the
biggest thing right and we we call it
the human firewall if we all if we all
behave well and and we don't make
mistakes that's the best protection any
organization can have so a lot of cyber
awareness training the other thing we're
doing is um doov in a box it's a
nationally recognized program and what
why what does in a box mean it means
when we go somewhere and we help them
get their domain to.gov we take them
from where they are we help them so if
somebody's fairly Advanced we have less
work to do if they're less Advanced we
have more work to do but we tailor that
program to them um in fact General Court
um congratulations you all just moved
to.gov domain very recently and that's a
big deal um it was very a very
challenging project that was funded
under the state and local cyber grant
program monies that helped um Terry PF
and his team and all of you get to
accomplishment followup so do you have
active Outreach with the counties in the
towns to make sure that as they upgrade
their systems that uh they're
coordinated like you said with like with
the whole primx thing do and and and and
it it goes through and we've been
building that the out it's not easy to
get to all of these entities and we've
been doing this for years and years and
the momentum is now building and so we
have the relationships that are growing
and building and again it's through
primex it's through the New Hampshire uh
Municipal Association it's through being
invited to events to present so that we
can share what we have we have a website
out there that uh if you if you uh
Google um New Hampshire doit you'll see
the uh the programs are pretty well
defined out there the committee that
decides on the allocation of these state
and local cyber Grant funds uh which is
specified by uh sisa who administer ERS
the program and and FEMA who deals with
the funds requires that we have
representation from the cities towns K
through 12s and County governments uh on
that so that we're not just sitting in
an ivory Tower deciding what to do but
rather getting input from those folks so
typically what we'll have
is there's more to do than we have money
to do so prioritization is important and
we do involve those entities in the
prioritization of the work thanks for
clarification thank you Mr chairman
representative Faulkner thank you Mr
chairman uh my question is what to what
extent do we rely on uh expertise at the
federal level
FBI other agencies in terms of U of
information and expertise in in
preventing cyber attacks and will
changes at the federal level affect what
we have to do
here so we partner very closely with the
sisa we have um that's okay
the legislation that was passed I want
to say maybe four years ago created a
position assisa coordinator for each
state we have a very involved sis
coordinator in New Hampshire I think one
of the best personally I think one of
the best in the country so we're we're
we benefit from that in fact we're doing
a a an exercise program later this week
with our our sisa
partners um and and that's and they're
all over the state trying to help out so
that's a huge help to us
FBI um we coordinate with them as well
in particular the FBI gets involved in
Secret Service Financial crimes division
in the cities towns and K through 12s if
there's a financial um aspect to a cyber
incident talk typically on the law
enforcement comes on the the back the
bad side of or incident response side of
an incident so the other the other
things we do is we involve sisa in the
development and our uh hscm Homeland
Security Emergency Management Group over
at Department of Safety in the
development of our incident response
plan for cyber incidents and uh as as
you may know um they we look at our
incident command through hsem as an all
hazards approach so if it's a flood or
if it's a ice storm or a cyber event it
gets handled similarly uh where if we if
we declare an incident then hscm is
incident command and we support them so
we're we're only incident command for
the you know the minor relatively minor
cyber incidents in the state and then
should there be a major incident uh we
would bring in uh HSM would take
incident command and in that case
depending on the severity of the
incident we would then bring in the FBI
or um or the um secret service Financial
investigation any further questions
representative
bogert thank you Mr chairman
um on page three of your thing you you
said you wanted to fund number one cyber
security and it was not approved but uh
Cloud Solutions and services was
approved uh could you tell me the reason
or the thought pattern behind why the
security portion was not approved and
the Cloud solution was
approved you know I I anticipated this
question and I don't know the answer to
that um I could just give you a little
bit overview on that though we we
normally don't get into any of those
kind of wise and wherefores because this
just comes out of the governors and this
is strictly done on on on monetary needs
and and what their feel are otherwise
obviously every one of these things
would have been improved in the order
that they wanted them
so we'll let you off the qu we'll let
you off the hook with that question sir
thank you Mr
chair do we have any other further
questions seeing none let's please move
on to uh the uh laps extension
information um so now we're on page
eight is a summary of our existing
Capital appropriation you can see in the
second column the original appropriation
and the remaining funds so I would I
would call out that we you know we are
we are utilizing These funds
actively uh so the main takeaway from
the first page we are asking that that
most of them be extended and um if you
wish I can take you through starting on
page nine in detail each one where we
are but but what I can say in summary is
is that you know we have plans to to
responsibly utilize These funds um over
the next year and a half or so so I I
would ask that we extend all the ones
except for the the two on uh that you
saw on page eight that one of them's
complete and the other has just a small
amount
left representative Jack yeah so uh to
so we we've confirmed number uh this is
going to be uh between 122 and 12 so
number
124 on Enterprise GIS alignment you
would like to lapse yes and well yes and
and again we've
um we we will be uh the remaining funds
we were using right now to integrate
that that 15,000 that remains we
basically be a we expect a zero lapse on
that um because we're going to use those
remaining funds to further integrate
our our current GIS mapping capabilities
in with our case management and our
licensing system that's systems that are
running on um salesforce.com I just like
you to make sure that you can actually
pay all the bills that you're going to
get on that line item before the end of
the fiscal
year um because after that you won't be
able to pay them yes we'll do okay well
that's what we're saying we know we know
we're going to encumber it that's not
the same so it's oh yeah good point yeah
so if it's it needs to be paid we are we
are adding to uh work that's already
being done but I don't know we would get
that paid by the end of the calendar or
so probably best utilize it leave it as
is I think the encumbrance is the key
key thing there
lapses seeing
none uh further questions regarding
their
presentation none seen thank you very
much gentlemen thank
you one one more Marty j y uh pre the
previous presentation was from
administrative Services they allowed us
to how they operate the Erp system that
does payroll and finance for the State
uh am I we we did some work in previous
bium about wrapping everything into
hosting everything on your systems so
that there weren't any agencies that had
systems that you didn't that you didn't
operate and that gets them within your
security trust perimeter so is that an
accurate way of yeah well the um New
Hampshire is a couple just interesting
points about New Hampshire we we are we
may be the most uh we may be the first
state that centralized uh it in the
country I think we mayit back in it
started back in 2003 and today we are
among the most centralized I think uh
Louisiana and and New
Hampshire um we as far as the executive
branch of government the cyber security
policy is an umbrella over the entire
executive branch so and we operate what
we call a baseline plus uh policy so our
cyber um policies are in effect for all
executive branch agencies and we we
hardly ever uh provide an exception to
those but what we do allow and and this
is appropriate is not all agencies carry
the same amount of or type of regulated
data so if the if the federal government
for example um requires let's take Dr
they have um you know they have the IRS
publication 1075 compliance requirements
we allow them to increase their cyber
posture improve it but not go back on it
so no agency can go below the Baseline
but an agency can go above the Baseline
for cyber security and and typically
they would do that to be in compliance
with a with a uh with a federal um
requirement so you know Dr is an example
of that
HHS almost every agency has some um you
know compliance requirements we're we're
being almost continuously audited by
some entity whether it be a Federal
agency or by the uh payment card
industry because we do process a lot of
of credit cards especially in the in the
Liquor
Commission further question yes
representative rockmore thank you Mr
chairman thank you um I'm new to the
committee so I want to be sure I'm
understanding
correctly my understanding from this
budget is that two years ago um you were
allocated over $2 million for cyber
security and now another over two
million is it so my question
is um is it your prediction that given
the current state of cyber crime in the
world that the state of New Hampshire
should expect to spend over a million
dollars a year on cyber security for the
foreseeable
future yes and and that that just keeps
us essentially it's a it's a it's a uh
capex to Opex hamster wheel um
essentially we invest in innovation in
cyberg to protect the state as it
changes during the bium should the
committee uh fund our
request and and then in the subsequent
that'll result in some operating expense
that will be in the sub subsequent um
bium to maintain
that and it keep the percentage of
that nationally keeps going going up I.E
the percentage
of uh cyber investment in operating
expense as a percentage of the entire
operating
expense so it's never
done any further questions
representative jurus thank you Mr
chairman uh commissioner briefly what
kind of network topology does does the
uh it system uh in New Hampshire have is
it a Sonet system or is it ethernet
based totally and do we
do we have our own in-house cable plant
do we lease a lot of circuits like uh T1
circuits
Etc um so the the um state has a
um an
internet an Ethernet Network that um
encompasses um you know close to um 400
locations just for the state Network so
that would be an Ethernet in the in the
um the location itself like take a uh
I'll use a Health and Human Service
district office as an example they have
a network sitting there they are
connected to us via Carri ethernet uh we
have um you know almost 400 Carri
ethernet circuits in New Hampshire
connecting physical locations to the
Mothership at 27 Hazen so that's your
Hub um we have a core Network that in
multiple uh internet connections we have
two major internet connections that are
redundant
uh with the appropriate Security on
those um both firewall as well as what
they call it IPS or an intrusion
protection system which allows us to do
things like geoblock we geoblock all
countries access to our Network except
for India and Canada Canada is more of a
um we we haven't experienced a lot of um
cyber attacks from Canada India is
because we actually have some
Contracting we have some contractors
that work in India for under contract
with a couple of different companies
that that we do business with that have
staff in India so we can't geoblock them
per se so um does that addition to the
400 locations there's a bunch of um
point-to-point VPN circuits that are
going into law enforcement entities and
the um the uh Town clerks and such
interfacing to DMV so the transactions a
a you know a registration transaction
really has data that belongs both in the
in the city or town that's doing it as
well as you know data has to flow up to
Hampshire further questions
representative Edgar uh thank you Mr
chair uh yeah thanks for taking my
question how is the security that's
arranged like with the secretary of
state for all the voting information I
know that that that's been in flux now
for a while the way we've been applying
our voting rules and
also you know the connections that are
made my my wife's are involved that so
um secretary estate scandin um has a
robust cyber security program we're
we're aware of it we partner with him we
we uh help each other out uh but
generally he has uh responsibility and
controls that and and um without sharing
in appropriate inappropriately sharing
details it's it's pretty in
depth oh thank you thank you Mr chair
thank you saying no further questions
gentlemen thank you very much for your
yeah
e
excuse me next up is the governor's
Works do we have a little handout from
this one or not do not have a handout oh
wonderful Governor's handout is right
here
uh that one
huh have a a brief statement then I'll
open it up for for questions uh good
morning Mr chairman and members of the
committee my name is James Gary and I'm
the governor I'm Governor AOS director
of policy and finance about a year ago
under Governor sonunu the state began
the process of putting together the
capital budget for the fiscal year 2026
2027 bium the various State departments
and agencies put together a list of
capital projects that they proposed
funding
last spring the Departments submitted
their request to the Department of
administrative services and the
governor's office the capital budget
hearings took place on June 18th and
19th of last year and after the capital
budget hearings the administrative
Services Department priced the projects
last
fall historically the state of New
Hampshire has funded in the neighborhood
of 120 to 130 million in capital
projects for each bium these projects
are paid for by the issuance of debt
that is secured by a general obligation
Pledge of the State of New Hampshire the
reason why we have typically not issued
significantly more is that there are
constraints on the amount of debt we can
issue our Capital position was
significantly improved with the recently
completed $990 million ARA allocation
from the federal government much of that
money going to capital projects but
while the state made a giant dent in the
pent up demand for long-term projects
much still needs to be done now there
are two main factors that constrain the
amount of debt that any municipality
including the state of New Hampshire can
issue New Hampshire is rated able A1
double A Plus able a plus by Moody
standard and pores and fit
respectively these rating agencies use
debt levels as a main component in the
rating process rating agency guidelines
from all three rating agencies are
closely monitored by the state treasurer
uh we have been assured by the state
treasurer that the governor's proposed
capital budget is well within the rating
agency's State guidelines of course
rating agencies guidelines are just one
potential roadblock the other of course
is can you afford the debt how much one
pays when they issue debt depends on the
bond ratings the interest rates the time
of the borrowing you know uh time of
year and what the economic conditions
are and the length of the borrowing term
for a typical $140 million deal at
current interest rates one would expect
deck service payments in the
neighborhood of a just under $9 million
per
year typically bonds will be issued with
the final maturity ranging anywhere from
15 to 30 years naturally they should
match the useful life of the project New
Hampshire has tended to frontload their
debt so the bonds amortise at a faster
rate than is typical for a state general
obligation Bond the rapid amotization of
debt has benefited New Hampshire by
lowering our levels of debt which has
led to a direct impact on New Hampshire
maintaining in even improving the
State's bond
ratings when the uh various departments
put their Capital requests together
their list was quite extensive in fact
the total amount submitted was just over
$1.3 billion with over 1.1 billion
coming from the general fund
sources with the state typically issuing
under 150 million of generally obligated
of generally funded uh bonds uh just for
retrospect in the current banum we
issued 130 million in the capital budget
with an additional 40 million coming
from an off- budget
session the governor had to whittle down
the list to something that the rating
agencies would accept and something we
could afford the governor's capital
budget does just that her Capital uh
budget has projects totaling 143 million
million payable from the fer fund and 27
million coming from all funding sources
government this diverse set of 41
projects the governor has identified
come from 16 different departments and
agencies within the state mercifully I
will not go through each of these
projects however they are projects there
are projects that I do want to single
out for your attention for
administrative Services their largest
risk is the 12.25 million ask for the
state Annex Renovations this is actually
phase two of a two-phase renovation
project phase two will
renovate the remaining office wings uh
into combined open and enclosed office
space and renovate the basement into
limited office space conference rooms
and mechanical spaces it should be noted
that the annex is a traditional home of
the Department of administrative
Services the state treasurer the
Department of Agriculture and parts of
the Secretary of State's and Governor's
Office three more projects are at the
Department of
Corrections uh the state of and this
shouldn't come as a a shock to many of
you but the state of New Hampshire needs
a new Men's prison to date the
legislature has authorized a total of 50
million for the new prison 40 million of
this authorization was in the form of
long-term debt that is yet to be issued
in all reality it will take almost
certainly in the neighborhood of 10
years before New Hampshire will see a
new Men's prison in the meantime we have
to maintain the current prison which is
costly therefore the governor has
proposed three projects at total $12
million for the Department of
Corrections that will provide much
needed basic maintenance at the Men's
prison and Conquer uh these projects
include HVAC Renovations and boiler
Replacements the governor has also
requested that $8.5 million be
appropriated in the capital budget for
the Jeffrey ring uh CTE renovation the
governor is a strong supporter of the CT
of of CTE schools and ask for your
support in this important project this
project will include a 30,000 square
foot addition that will provide areas to
add cosmetology culinary arts fire EMT
security and public safety
programs finally I wanted to point out
the dncr request of $20 million for the
Canon Mountain tram many of you may
remember that in the current budget the
legislature appropriated $18 million in
cash to dncr sorry sorry dncr to
purchase a new tram that money was never
spent uh the reason why was the cost of
the tram came in well above budget and D
dncr went back to the drawing board to
come up with a new tram plan uh that is
more costeffective and that is where we
are now given the useful life of the
tram is over 30 years it made far more
sense for the state state to use that
$18 million for current expenditures of
the state and pay for the tram out of
the capital budget and the governor's
hb2 budget the $18 million in cash that
was appropriated from the general fund
will lapse back into the general fund uh
on on July 1 of 2025 in its place there
is a $20 million ask for the tram in the
capital budget uh given the legislator's
appropriation for the $18 million for
the tram the governor wanted to be sure
that the money for this project was
placed in her capital budget for your
consideration overall the projects the
governor has chosen for the capital
budget represent a diverse group of
departments and projects that share one
thing in common they are badly needed we
realize that there are numerous other
projects that the governor has chosen
not to fund that are also important and
just as badly needed so we will
certainly not be offended if your list
is slightly different than ours uh with
that I'll be more than happy to open it
up for questions thank you thank you sir
any
questions representative CIA uh yes uh
Mr chairman just all I hope you'll take
this in with all due respect to the
governor as far as the tram line I think
it's an important project for tourism
and it's got 20 million but I've heard
it's going to cost a lot more as much as
32 million do you does a governor or you
have any ideas where we could get those
additional funds uh I think the 20
that's what we're in the process now of
of looking to see what it will cost and
I think what they're trying to do and um
my my understanding is that is a
difference between just the tram and the
towers as well and if we can get it to
where we can use the existing Towers the
price will come down
significantly uh so that's where we are
and uh the governor obviously does
support the project because if if she
didn't it wouldn't be in here um but but
it's the cost I mean if if it's
exorbitant costs then we may have to go
look look El s um at a different type of
project for that because it is a revenue
generator it is good for tourism it is
good for the North country and all those
things the governor is is very
supportive of followup Mr chair followup
oh yes so you think we could you could
get the price down because the towers
maybe down to about $20 million you can
find some savings or do the postpone the
projects for later that is that is our
hope and if we can't then the money
would have to come and in and if the
legislature agreed to fund the project
then the money would have to come
um either
by uh increasing the capital budget or
obviously taking it out from from other
projects thank you thank you Mr chairman
thank I think it I'm I'm glad it was
important to note that the 18 million
that we had
previously committed to this went back
into they did not spend that money they
didn't spend that money they're starting
off part of the reason why the 20 is
here uh anyway yes was it represent L
thank you Mr chair chairman thank you
taking my
question so is there uh on the issue of
the the Tramway um how many bids have
you gotten on that on that
project I'm I'm not sure about that I
believe it was just one I I I I I
believe it's just one and that's that's
why the project came to an immediate
halt right there there there's not a lot
of companies that
Supply this type of equipment and and do
this type of job okay thank you any
other question Jess representative B
thank you Mr chairman you said the
revenue generator how much revenue will
be you can be made to offset what we're
spending uh the projections I've seen
from uh from from dncr I mean I I
believe it's in the in the neighborhood
of over a million dollars a
year so it's it's uh it's it's it's
significant Revenue that they can bring
in and then there's and and that's
that's the direct Revenue uh there's
also the indirect revenue of it is a a
tourism generator it is it it it may not
be the sole reason why people come to
New Hampshire or or go to the North
country but it is a it is a reason and
uh it's certainly one that uh when you
think of the iconic right New Hampshire
symbols that's one of them thank
saying none thank you very much sir
thank you I'm gon to maybe make a
mistake and answer a question that was
asked previously about the I know which
one you're going to go right ahead I
want to put you on I didn't want to put
you on the spot but go right Ahad about
the it appreciate the way you hand that
Mr chairman
um with that cyber security is is
certainly something that is extremely
important to the state and extremely
important to the governor and uh is
something that should be considered the
reason why it was wasn't put in here was
mly because of other priorities and and
the fact that cyber security had been
funded previously both through in the
capital budgets uh previously and
through some arpa allocations so while
those while cyber security is is
absolutely uh important to the state and
something that should be considered uh
she just thought one of the things was
the the cloud services is also an
important issue as as now that the state
is switching to a cloud service to make
sure we have the proper funding for that
so it again it's it's picking a um a
project that really hadn't been uh
funded in the past for one that had and
and that's really what it was nothing
nothing more but if you choose to fund
cyber security we're certainly not going
to
object thank you for that clarification
like I said I didn't want to put you on
the spot and but no you you're happy
representative bogert thank you for the
the answer okay thank you sir thank you
for
coming folks we've got uh we're a little
bit ahead of schedule here so uh let let
me just give you a fast
rundown what we're in for we're uh we've
got an additional $6 M80 th000 worth of
extra requests so far but through our
laps program representative Jack what do
we got 5,2 $67 to good well I have
D so you'll you'll notice that we'll get
a lot more requests than than people
giving up money and that's one we'll
we'll get into the tough decisions later
on but once again this is just strictly
their uh their wish lists and their
presentations so thank you very much and
we'll see you back here at about just
want to uh make sure that judicial
branch will not be here at 1:00 so your
first agency will be the Department of
Education and they should be here about
1:30 um I had handed out to everybody a
copy of a page of an email that
basically says that um judicial branch
is going to withdraw the project request
the
$157,000 uh$ 157 and $950,000 um project
um the reason they couldn't be here
wasn't because of that they had some
administrative issues getting people
here
but they did want to know that let the
committee know that they were
withdrawing that
project 157,000 back into the good side
representative bogert uh point of
clarification in the
it uh
$7,950
request from sorry is that the same fund
yes yes yeah that's the exact same
project that's being
withdrawn thank you very much that's
where it gets a little squirrly that's
why I was getting him to try to explain
that the do
doit
has signs off on all these projects
right and commits to them but they come
out of those departments budgets
so so when it looks like as if let's see
what six six actual requests only one of
doit representative fauler question that
you might might be able to answer is
that some talk about non-general fond
sources for some of these Bond payments
can we kind of go over what
um what funds I know there's fishing
game fund about the highway fund are
there
other funds that we draw on that have
their own
dedicated revenues that
U
and what flexibility is there to those
are normally listed most of the time
like when we get into uh military side
those are mostly federal funds but when
we get into the do you'll see that some
of the funds come from Highway funds
some of them come from Turnpike funds I
think we have some uh part of the
natural cultural resources from Mr chair
if I'm might help with that question so
if you look at your house bill 25
document that I passed out today and if
two and that's where you have the
fishing game
projects and then on lines 14 through 18
there's a note there that tells you the
source of the funds what those other
funds are that would fund that project
in this case it's very clear it's
fishing game for the dancer projects
there'll be a similar note for that as
well
um so it depends on the agency and if
they have dedicated funding to to come
forward with liquor fund is another one
you don't have any projects this year
but you've seen them in the past in this
committee where they come in and um ask
to do a store renovation and they fund
it with liquor funds um Highway fund is
a separate section within the house bill
25 um the dancer has used um excuse me
not dancer Environmental Services has
used the
winaki River Basin um funding that's a
dedicated group of communities that have
a um water treatment plant that's run by
the Environmental Services they collect
revenue from those um agencies to do
Capital Pro those communities to do
capital projects and I believe there's
25 I hope that answers the question
representative any other questions or
concerns Mr representative J thank you
Mr chairman uh just is it unusual back
to the judicial branch is it
unusual that agency not to request any
Capital appropriations of funding they
they don't request a lot a lot of what
they've requested over the last uh few
Capital budgets has been for an ecourt
more recently it was the digitization
digitization of their records um I'm not
sure why they just may not be ready as
as a as a branch to move forward with
the project and that you watch maybe why
they're not asking for this additional
funding but I didn't get an exact reason
they just said we want to withdraw our
request interesting thank you anybody
else Mr chair a question I just want to
be sure if I heard this right when the
Mr Gary just said something about the
state has just received I think $992
million in arpa additional arpa funds no
that's what they spent they spent they
spent okay fine thank you I misheard
them
1:30
e
it being around 130ish let's continue
with the with the uh capital budget
presentations and I'd like to call on
next welcome to public
works thank you good afternoon Melissa
white division director for learner
Support Department of
Education Tammy Valen cour the CFO for
Education so I provided three
packets the first packet is the
presentation from the Department of
Education and then there's Al also two
additional packets that contain
information provided
um from the districts from the CT
centers with plans budgets and just some
background information so that you have
that available to look through also here
today are representatives from each of
the centers so if there's any specific
questions um they are available to come
up and answer any questions that we
might have about the specific
projects okay thank you well then I
guess I've got the I'll lead off with
the first question because we are
showing a request for 18 , 518,000 for
the Jeffrey ringe CTE renovation and if
I'm reading this correctly your new
updated request is for $16
m46 th000 is that correct that is
correct you're going to be invited back
here more often if you keep doing things
like
this the these things these kind of
things make us happy uh so this is for
um and for all the new members here we
we go through this
every bium we do we have a regular
schedule on on schools that we support
the CTE project and it's a 75 I believe
it's 7525 match is that correct that's
correct so if you could please walk us
through do we have the money commitment
from Jeffrey ring yet from the town for
that project they are going to their
vote on March 11th
okay now correct me if I'm wrong uh Mr
Shay if they do
not vote to pass this then it normally
goes to we will still take they will
still stay in the same position on our
list but we
will try and fund it for the next school
on the list which I believe is
Milford so since it's going to be going
to the March meeting you would if this
is the desire of the committee to have
this CTE project funded you would keep
it in the capital budget let the Senate
then address it if it
fails that's okay thank you that's what
I needed to
know okay then uh continue There is an
additional project that uh we wanted to
put forth to the committee to consider
and that's the Milford applied
Technology Center with a request of 9.8
million that is not included in the
governor's recommended budget
okay too bad you couldn't have reduced
that original 18 down about another 7
million we would have taken care of both
correct okay and then I take it these
are your
um this money isn't in either in in
lapse requests is it uh Mr Shay they
they gave us the information for Sugar
River Valley and winnisquam what's still
there so those two
projects um will not are not anticipated
to have any lapse funding okay at this
time those were eventually funded out of
the education trust fund and have
non-aps funds both centers have stated
that they anticipate expending all of
their
funds okay and that's on page three
background information on that I just
didn't remember going through the
capital budget for
that all right do we have any
questions representative Boyd oh just a
point of order Mr chairman when we had
broke the lunch it was brought to my
attention that this committee will have
a full work session on Mark March 18th
at 10: a.m. so I want to revisit the
question regarding Jeffrey ringe that
it's actually going to be our our group
that will be dealing with that issue and
Senate yeah there you go okay thank
you I'd also like to um just mention
that Milford also is going to vote on
March 11th so we'll have that
information as well at at that work
session perfect thank you very much any
other
questions yes representative alone thank
you very much Mr chairman uh thank you
for taking my question on
the vote on March 11th is there a an
warrant article for a revote for a
second a special meeting after to follow
in case it fails so if it fails it fails
it's done just want to get that clarify
not in either town so not in uh Jaffrey
ring or in Milford great thank you okay
representative Jack yeah if we can take
up the laps extensions for a moment are
you ready to do that yes um you have
four the winnisquam actually is outside
the purview of this committee at this
point because it was funded in House
Bill 2 out of the education trust fund
correct so that and now we have uh in
2021 we have an item for generator
installation at Walker building that is
not requested for a lapse extension we
would assume that's complete and if you
would just confirm you don't need that
extended that would be good that is
correct that project did not move
forward and that was funded with federal
funds and the yeah I have that and then
the one after that is pre-engineering
technology in 20121 item
two there's about
$199,900 available and those will lapse
come 6:30 okay so there is 19,000 in the
pre-engineering technology correct right
that's good and then uh we have item 73
in the capital budget is the
bathrooms uh at the where you previously
were located the building yes that is
Lan Hall so that that would that would
continue that is continuing they expect
that project to be completed come August
of 25 okay thank
questions seeing none thank you very
much for
you we're running way ahead of schedule
is the police standards and training
here
well that that was that was quick that
was a whole lot of people for very short
presentation
huh support noral support since we have
a a minute I just wanted to let members
know that I added some more paper to
your pile just after lunch and one of
the documents is the tracking sheet that
has been typically used in the past by
this committee um as you make decisions
it kind of helps you kind instead of
having to look in the pink uh document
or the house bill 25 it gives you a way
to track Decisions by this committee um
and one of them I didn't change on it
yet but you could if you wanted to cross
it off is on the second page is judicial
branch you basically that's project
won't go forward so it stays as zero in
the house column and it would be either
re-budget it somewhere else for a
away for those those of you who haven't
been here before we use this worksheet
when we start after all the
presentations are done and we start
going into the reg after the public
hearing we will start doing this going
through here line by line we'll be for
instance the uh Department of
administrative Services wheel going okay
they asked for 1.5 million you notice
our column under house says zero we will
sit here as a group and decide was that
an adequate request the governor
approved it is there they they still
want it do we want to approve that
amount do we want to approve a little
bit more or a little bit less so that
this will actually be our worksheet and
when all of this is finally done then we
will and all of Representatives Jack's
laps extensions what the laps extensions
will do is give us additional money
money that's already been budgeted spent
and they didn't use it all for projects
that we can decide to whether to let it
lapse into um the general fund or I'll
just pick a number call it 200,000 is
left or we can decide to say say hm
we're short uh 200,000 on on this second
request for somebody and we can add it
to that so although we though this is
the governor's capital
budget this being the house Public Works
committee we put in our final numbers
and that's what we will be voting on
when we're done it'll go to the Senate
the Senate will go through the same
process so the governor's budget is just
a guideline a very wellth thought out
guideline but we will have the final say
so on that so these are very important
worksheets to keep representative alone
thank you Mr chair I got a question so
we're already looking at $2
million less so what we going to do with
that money for now will we park it on
the Shelf do we sort of just keep in the
back of our heads I mean right now yeah
well we've once again it was $2 million
however if you notice
um Das asked for 5 million more their
erf program and the department of
Information Technology asked for an
additional million 180 so we'll have
requests on one side we'll
have gains on the other side and uh when
we get to our final work sessions on all
this we as a group are going to decide
look what have we got in this column
what column is it going to go into so
does that money kind of go with the laps
money that we're talking about or is
that just that no that that money is
already in in the budget yeah and it
just hasn't been spent yet it hasn't
been put into any column now yet so all
the laps money will add to that and
we'll have a different figure going to
be
fun you haven't done this before have
you there fund does not come into this
example Mr chairman I'm on uh I'm the
vice chair of the budget committee and
that I know all that fun okay all right
well let's let's just let's we'll just
be informal from now until uh
1:30 yeah if uh someone were new and
they were interested in this repurposing
from laps money scenario if you go and
look at last times House Bill 25 the
2023 version after the first part that
does all the new appropriation there's a
section that does all the repurposing
and re and you can look in there as to
how the money is lapsed and reallocated
so it's basically handled with the with
Amendment having said that on
Friday the
14th there's going to be a subcommittee
for the laps extensions the subcommittee
consists of representative Jack
representative Newman representative
Boyd representative Brown and
representative bogert it's a five-person
committee we are you are all invited to
come to that
session and participate if you'd like it
only takes three four five people and
this is the first time we have ever ever
brought in the lapses during this part
of the uh presentation normally we do
them all separate but we found out that
over the years only two or three people
ever know what the heck we're talking
about when it comes to lapses so this
way we we're having it presented in
front of all of us so we know they exist
and all your question questions are are
very well welcomed and they'll all get
answered but the final thing after
Marty's committee
meets during our first scheduled session
after
that they will present us a figure that
says oh by the way you now have an
additional $1.3 million to add into your
or add or keep or give to the general
funds as a general rule we find a place
to end
it good just so everyone's clear uh we
don't take any votes at the subcommittee
so anyone is free to come sit at your
regular place ask questions you know
it's just same as if you were on the
committee we have to name specifically
name people on to the committee so that
it's official but we was always done it
10 our next meeting is the 18th
10 our next meeting is scheduled for
next Monday it was I scheduled it for
Tuesday because I was keeping everything
on Tuesdays and then we found out it was
town meeting day in my ignorance I
overlooked that so
we so next Monday we will also be
meeting for the second half of all these
presentations you said the
18 the
18th 18th will be the Public heing
Public hearing at 10:00 a.m. it normally
lasts about a half hour and as soon as
the public hearing is open we will go
into our work session where we start
saying no no yes give give them an extra
them hopefully
day we'll
see we'll
see correct well I'm just talking about
General work sessions how long so start
having your own little ideas
representative bogur already has a
little idea of what he wants to do with
Mr Shay just um in helping the committee
kind of think about today's agencies you
have the department of safety coming in
at
two 220 is um you'll see that there's
two projects for the Department of
Safety uh the automated fuel tax system
and the gun range training
facility those
and I checked with the the you know you
saw the commissioner was here in the
hall for a moment and I ran up to him to
ask him a question the question was
should this be Highway funded bonds or
should this be General funded bonds so
he's looking into that we believe it
should be Highway funded so it may be
shifting out of the general fund into
the highway Fund in terms of the source
of fund
request for for both projects yeah yeah
um he's he's going to check on that make
sure that that's correct but the fuel
tax system I would
think that that's what started the
conversation um and then he was looking
at the gun range and he was thinking
that might also be um Highway
funded at least by to some extent so
just so the committee is kind of aware
of that when the presentation comes in
and he starts to talk about Highway fund
general fund that's where that that may
be coming from and you may want to um
further prod and and ask questions
related to that just to make sure it's
gentlemen welcome to welcome to Public
Works police standards and training
Council
gentlemen
proceed good afternoon for the record uh
my name is Mark O'Brien I'm assistant
director for police stand and training
um regretfully director Skipper cannot
meeting our mission is the shape and
strength and sustain the compid and
Professionals of New Hampshire law
enforcement in service to our state the
police STS and training Council
regulates the hiring Education
certification standards for all police
State Corrections probation and parole
officers in New Hampshire we operate the
New Hampshire Police Academy which all
Municipal Police County Sheriff deputies
state troopers conservation
officers liquor investigators and other
full-time Law enfor Officers must attend
to become certified and the full-time
police officer in this state we also
operate the part-time officer basic
training classes that all part-time
police officers must complete to obtain
part-time police officer
certifications as well as New Hampshire
Corrections Academy that all State
Corrections Officers attend in order to
obtain their corrections officer
certifications we also provide
specialized Advanced and inservice
refresher training at our facility in
conquered and Regional around the state
to assist officers in completing the
annual requirement to maintain their
certifications we are an independent
executive branch
agency governed by 17 member member
police standards and training Council we
are not affiliated with any law
enforcement or prosecut prosecutorial
agency thereby avoiding any potential
conflicts of interests with our
regulatory function and desertification
duties we provide services with 20 28
full-time uh 28 full-time and 11
part-time positions which includes sworn
staff administrative and maintenance
employees our staff is assisted by agin
instructors most of whom are unpaid and
they
volunteer and a small number of
contracted
instructors we operate a
77,000 square foot training facility
facility located on 20.8 7 Acres of
ground across from nhti conquered
if I go too fast please let me
know present facility conditions we are
in desperate need of more classroom and
office space as well as more secure
facility on the public entrance to
provide background the following is
offered our current facility was
constructed in three
phases phase one which is the main
building houses the administrative
offices main lobby two
classrooms classroom one and two one
small lecture hall which is lecture hall
one they were finished in
1983 lecture hall one while rated for
maximum capacity by New Hampshire fire
Marshall's office they rate it at 73 can
comfortably hold 50 students as it's
currently
configured classroom one and two which
are rated for maximum capacity at 38 can
comfortably hold 30 as each one is
currently
configured lecture hall one is used
primarily for holding both police and
Corrections and occasionally when it's
available we will hold inservice
classes classroom one and two are used
primarily for inservice classes and for
large meetings such as monthly Council
meetings phase two this phase of the
building was completed in 1986 and added
two more classrooms classroom three and
classroom 4 also lecture hall 2 eight
small officers for the trainers and a
multi-purpose room lecture hall 2 was
configured to hold 110 students but was
reconfigured years ago reducing the
capacity per the fire Marshall's office
to 73 but configured to comfortably hold
55 this room is exclusively used for the
full-time Police
Academy classroom three and four were
used for inservice classes breakout
rooms for the Academy Squad meetings
group projects scenario training in 2013
classroom 3 and four were reconfigured
to house a vert training
simulator this device is used about 25%
of the year to provide lowcost highly
controlled and safe firearms and
decision-making training the
multi-purpose room called the break room
was initially used for Hands-On training
such as physical fitness defensive
tactics training baton training
presently due to the construction of
phase three of the facility this room is
now used for scenario training
occasionally a break
room phase three this phase of the
facility was completed in 1992 consisted
of a residence Wing being attached to
the south end of the building and the
Tactical Center added to the north end
of the building the Tactical Center's
first floor is a large multi-purpose
room that is used for all skills classes
excuse me such as fit Fitness training
defensive tactics training baton
training as well as scenario training is
also used for large scale meetings and
for all
graduations the upstairs houses a 20
Lane indoor firing range that is used
for all Academy and inservice Firearms
classes as well as a small track that
runs along the outside of the
range FY 26 capital budget request for
your consideration we respectfully make
the following Capital Improvement
projects request and three laps
project one New Hampshire police
standards and training is an urgent need
of physical security improvements for
the recruits in service training
officers guests civilians employees and
training Specialists the main building
was designed and constructed in the
early 80s with no consideration for
restricting access to the facility the
facility regularly has over 100 unarmed
police officer recruits and correction
officer recruits as well as many unarmed
instructors
and actors for scenarios that are
providing recruit training we also have
unarmed full-time and part-time civilian
staff restricting access to only those
authorized is imperative for the safety
and future of continued success of the
mission of
PST this project would provide for the
installation of doors in the hallways
leading from the lobby and recruit
dormitories that are currently have
unrestricted access to anyone from
outside the building the project would
also doors and access control in the
main entrance of the facility provide
cameras and intercom capabilities to
allow pstc staff to control entry to the
facility PST has previously requested
security improvements in FY 24 and fy2
capital budget process and was denied
during the governor's phase we
respectfully request that this important
security project be approved for FY 26
and 27 capital budget the total request
is is 480,000 it is included in the
governor's capital
budget stop you right there let's uh
this is this is the the request side so
let's get any questions we have right
now any questions for the gentleman
bogert thank you Mr chairman just a
clarifying question uh in U phase one uh
you indicated that your classroom was
being used for police and
Corrections uh
academics acmis okay is the correction
part all the correction officers have to
go to this
Academy and if so I was also under the
impression the corrections has to get
certified through uh Municipal and
County
govern agency of some sort and I'm kind
of confused why two
different accreditations have to happen
for a corrections officer
please um we certify All State
Corrections County correction officers
have their own Academy because they're
with a County facility we do the state
of New Hampshire Corrections for the
state
yes please and why is that if it's a
Corrections there's not much difference
between corre I mean yes there's
differences but uh you still have
prisoners at state level and they're
prisoners at the county level why would
there be a need for two different types
of uh accreditation for
this we certify the state correct
and the county has their own curriculum
which we will sign off on but we do not
Corrections questions been made and
answered any other further questions
representative jurus thank you thank you
Mr chairman
so as of so right now I can I can roll
over to that facility park my car and
just walk in and walk around unimpeded
you could somebody ask a question uh you
know maybe I could show him a badge or
something an ID I could you know just
just kind of go as I please we do have
signs that say no unauthorized Personnel
but you could walk down the hallways you
could walk right into the lecture hall
where the recruits are currently at
right now there's no there's no CCTV
system there's no access control as of
right
now okay there is a camera there's a few
cameras in the building but they're not
going to stop somebody from walking in
and just going so this includes both
physical
and this monitoring uh Rec and recording
yes thank
you repres representative Lewis thank
you Mr chairman uh have there been
issues as to why this has come come
about what that you you you guys wanted
to your department wanted to address
this at this
that thank you for your question my name
is ma Schultz I'm the administrator in
charge of our Bureau of support services
so I think this is something that police
standards and training uh Administration
has wanted to do is to secure the
entrance for quite a few years uh we
have had several instances over the
years where we've had people who are
unhoused who would just show up in our
lobby and be laying in our lobby or we
would have to get medical attention for
them that we weren't aware they were
there so I think these type of
instances uh certainly caused Great
concern to for protection of not just
our staff but of all the visitors and
other police agencies that are attending
training that may be unarmed and unaware
of who might be in the building because
we can't control the physical barriers
in the hallways and things you could
literally walk in our front lobby go up
the stairs and go to the dorm rooms for
the recruits you could go to any of the
lecture halls and training it just was
not designed for those physical barrier
impediments
thank you thank you Mr just just just
for your information I I don't think I I
think what you asked was did anything
just trigger this and I believe he said
nothing just trigger this but this has
been in past budget requests for at
least the last two or four years uh just
didn't get approved that's all so they
have requested this before any other
questions representative fauler yes
thank you I know this isn't part of your
request but you mentioned the uh firing
range at your headquarters is
that who who is that available to is it
all police officers or just those in
training or uh how is that
managed So currently any and all police
officers use that range to qualify to
complete the academy also for our
inservice program they have to come back
and redo their inservice for instructor
CS um if there is a request for that
range that would go if there's somebody
because of bad weather and they need to
go out and qualify their officers they
have to submit the request through the
director and if it's available he will
make it available for them if could
assist most of the agencies have their
own ranges we do it for our
training thank you one final question
representative Edgar uh thank you Mr
chair and thanks for answering my
question um the question I have is that
you have um said that you also do the
parttime officers and I know that the
last time that uh Mr Skippy was in we
asked him about uh that program being
reinstituted and I was told it was I
just was wondering how many how many
people have been serviceing recently in
the
parttime so my since I've been there the
parttime has dropped right now the
current class has 18 recruits in
it thank you thank you Mr chair you're
welcome I seeing no further questions
let's go ahead and move on to the laps
the lap extension request one we request
a laps extension the appropriation made
by the police standards and training
Council in
2019 um for a boiler replacement which
was amended by House Bill 1043 in 2024
session to include replacing our
tactical Center floor and facility
improvements boiler controllers AC
Replacements and the range the boil
replacement was nearly completed when
during the final phase of the
construction project the engineers
discovered that a hot water tank and
piping would need to be replaced and
high uh hot water high temperature
issues with the recruit showers would
need to be addressed for safety Public
Works initiated a DPW project number
8111 7c domestic hot water system
upgrade now Public Works has advised
that they Cann not get this job
completed prior to the end of this bium
and requested that we ask for funds to
be available for the next banum the
delay is due to the Das Public Works
prioritizing arpa projects above Capital
funded projects project was included in
the extension list in the governor's
capital budget therefore respectfully
request that this project be
extended there is currently available
$125,200 exension request two request a
lapse extension for the appropriation
made to the police stand of training
Council in
2023 it's to move the vert simulator
this project will move the virt
simulator to an existing outbuilding and
reclaim classroom three and four back to
the original state it will provide us
with two classrooms to hold inservice
classes us as an academy breakout room
provide rooms for scenario training this
project was included in the extension
list in the governor's capital budget
this is currently available this is a
300,000 lap extension three request a
laps extension for the appropriation
made to the police stands and training
Council in 2023 it's to convert the
break room to a
classroom this project will also allow
us to add additional office for staff
and it will provide us with an
additional classroom to hold inservice
classes use as an academy breakout room
room for scenario to training this
project is included in the extension
list in the governor's capital budget
this is a current this is current
available balance of 150,000 in this
account in our conclusion we are
respectfully requesting one Capital
Improvement project to be addressed our
urgent need of physical security
improvements to the public entrance for
the recruits inservice training officers
guests civilian employees and training
Specialists we are requesting the three
laps extensions for our existing and
approve funding for three capital
projects that have been delayed by NHD
public works and that will provide more
classroom space so that we can
adequately address the present and
future training needs and mandates
within Hampshire law enforcement thank
you for listening to our presentation
they stand right to answer any questions
that you may
have representative Jack do you have any
questions regarding the lapses uh no I
think uh we're good they're all extended
and that's
it any further question questions yes
representative
voyd thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my
question on average every year how many
full-time and part-time recruits go to
the police standards
Academy currently we're doing three
classes we're estimated to be around 195
full-time if all the classes fill the
part-time uh currently is at 18 but that
one can go up to 20
to30 and Corrections um currently their
next class a very big class it's going
to be around 38 and our cant the they
also will have 18 civilian staff that'll
probably be in so they'll probably be at
50 when they come in all up Mr chairman
follow
up for the Men's prison and the women's
prison on a what's what's the St what's
the max St you're not commissioner hon I
apologize I was just wondering if you
knew what the Staffing level was ly at
the at the men's or the women's prison
just off the tub sorry unfortunately I
don't have that fair enough sorry to put
you on the spot I apologize thank you Mr
chairman representative B thank you Mr
chairman and follow up on representative
Boyd's question with your total a year
for a police officers being
trained uh last year was 21 we were
slotted for I don't have the exact
numbers of if you're mean exact well
graduates um currently right now our
academies will take 64 for three
sessions we were doing
210 last year for
sessions representative jurus thank you
Mr chairman so on the on this on this
track uh are sounds like we're we're
graduating recruits for for cops on the
on the state level and in the uh in the
uh prisons I mean sounds like this
number should be going up we should we
should should the Staffing level should
be
better with with the amount of with just
the way of using the
facility yes uh if the classes fill um
and that's the beginning of the classes
unfortunately there is an attrition rate
on some of the classes what's the
graduation I follow up thank you thank
you graduation rate 90% or better uh I
would say it's less than that um our
last class we only had 39 recruits
attend out of 50 and that was in
December this class we started with 64
we're currently at 60 to graduate but
they're only halfway through gotcha
thank you thank you further
questions saying none gentlemen thank
presentation we have Department of
Safety scheduled at 2:20 if they are
uh Mr chair I just want to correct I
suggested to the committee earlier that
when they came up we'd talk about
Highway funds versus General funds
correct um in talking with the
commissioner and his business
administrator the reason that the
general funds are being used it has to
do with the health of the highway fund
so there's not enough money to do
projected to do the bonding that would
be required for these projects so the
general fund appropriation is correct
that's my error steering you the wrong
way thank you for that information and
not good news to hear about the highway
welcome to public
works please begin good afternoon Mr
chair members of the committee my name
is Robert quid and I serve as the
commissioner of the Department of Safety
accompanying me today is Amy Newbery our
director of administ
we're here to present the department of
safety's FY 2627 capital budget requests
which have been approved by Governor
aach additionally would' like to discuss
a project that we believe warrants
reconsideration these Capital
Investments are essential to fulfilling
our mission to continually enhance the
safety security and quality of life in
the Hampshire through professional
collaborative and Innovative service to
all our proposed projects support
critical training for the division of
State Police and include an IT
initiative with broad community and
stakeholder impact generating
significant revenue for the state Amo
will also provide a brief update on
projects for which we have requested and
a lapse extension as well of those that
have been successfully completed
following our presentation we'll both be
happy to answer any questions Amy good
afternoon like the commissioner said I'm
Amy Newbery director of administration
the department of safety um I'm going to
jump right into the PowerPoint on page
three is our um two projects listed that
were approved by the governor and then
our one additional request of you
today on page
four so this is the automated fuel tax
system and this system is a crucial tool
used by the Department of Safety
Division of administration the road toll
Bureau it is to collect Road tools for
the motor Fuel and alternative fuels
this system represents the single
largest source of revenue for the
highway Fund in addition to fuel taxes
afts collects various fees on behalf of
the Department of Environmental Services
once collected all fees and taxes
gathered through afts are interfaced
with New Hampshire first the State's new
the state's enterprise resource planning
system the current system is end of life
and must be replaced to continue to
collect the highway Fund in summary the
in New Hampton that is an urgent need of
significant upgrades currently the
existing training building is under
sized and relying on generator power
which limits it its
functionality Additionally the facility
lacks restrooms and running water making
it difficult to utilize the range year
round these limitations hinder
effectiveness of the training programs
and restrict its overall utility for law
enforcement and other agencies
through building a properly sized
training facility that meets the needs
of New Hampshire State Police and other
agencies connecting the facility to
Electric utilities eliminating the need
for generator power want to install
running water and restroom facilities
providing basic amenities that are
essential both for operating
efficiencies and comfort Personnel um
expanding the range area to accommodate
a broader range of training scenarios
and provide greater opportun for skill
development and these improvements could
benefit other benefit other state
agencies as well including kushion game
Municipal police departments such as
those in New Hampton and more functional
and accessible training facilities would
enhanced training capabilities across
multiple agencies promoting safety
efficiency and Inter agency
cooperation so before I move on to our
requested um our next requested um
Capital project do you have questions
about these
two yes I believe we do representative
Boyd thank you Mr chairman and I
apologize Amy what is your last name
Newbery Newbery I apologize Miss
Newberry thank you for your testimony
and I appreciate you taking my question
um prior to your testimony we heard from
two individuals representing the police
standards and training Council regarding
some of their projects and and their
facility concerns and they have a gun
range at their particular facility that
is available upon request and I'm just
um curious to know what prevents the
State Police from coordinating with the
police standards training facility to
Facility I think that our needs are go
beyond what they can provide there
that's an indoor range um we're
generally shooting twice a year we also
do use of force defensive tactics we're
shooting rifles so I believe that um I
don't think that that that could meet
our needs plus our plus the amount of
Troopers that were rotating through
there we generally need to be outside
too to incorporate some of the um
vehicle stops and just different
scenarios that they do I appreciate the
Canda thank you no thank
you I'm going to ask a question
following up on that I know that the uh
Governor Cog G is been having meetings
and I know this was a topic of one of
the things um there are obviously
numerous gun ranges run by various
police and other departments where would
where do you rate this your your
department of safety one I in overall
are you able to accommodate more and
more uh other departments if we were to
to get you this money and and move it
forward or would you say you're one of
the smaller less well no that's used
like
that's a fair question and I think you
know anytime you look at an investment
you have to look if there's 365 days in
the year um how many days are we using
it and then you know could it be
expanded to allow others to use it I
think you know the answer is yes we
could definitely look at that but again
we cycle a lot through there's a lot of
training that gets done there and um so
if you're looking for efficiency I think
that is definitely a a question to ask
and I can bring that up in our our coach
if we're investing in this are there
others that might want to be able to use
it like Amy said there are other state
agencies state law enforcement agencies
that um go through the same Police
Academy um we we we're always um willing
to share our resources we're one state
so I think the answer is yes thank you
very much uh representative rockmore you
had a question earlier did it get
answered during that presentation or not
it did thank you it did okay thank you
repres representative fauler I'm sorry
representative kazinski thank you I'm so
used to see
down there with this is an outdoor range
with rifles how how is this 100 yard
range or 200 yards or I think right now
the trying to go back the last time we
were at 50 100 we're trying to go back
too to expand it to at least that for
the
rifles
okay um on this building what what type
of a building is this going to be like a
garage or is it this is B I mean we what
we're in now sir is a basic slab you
know
t111 asphalt roof that's had mold um it
has been
there I go back as far as I can remember
there's never been any enhancement to it
we've had a porta party there at times
there's no running water um it's it's
definitely a life end yeah I got that
picture there but I'm asking what what
the new building would be like because
it's I'm looking at the request here and
I'm trying to Envision that I I think
like everything we do we try to be
pretty basic not to overbuild it so if
you're looking at the dimensions I think
it will meet our needs with um I mean if
you're looking for the construction
materials is is that you asking I was
kind of concerned what kind of building
is because I I have a large
garage is this a garage type building I
would say so
yeah I don't think it's a Morton
Building a steel but we're looking at a
23x 20 building you know just basic
construction well that's the one you
have now right right so we're looking at
feet two
classrooms dedicated office weapons
questions representative jur thank you
thank you Mr chairman
uh so this building was originally
conceived when and and was it just a
place to go and and and begin you know
just target practice or something and
then a building was installed
and how did this get to this point I
guess is my first question I can tell
you how I want to go back
I remember when it was built I think it
was some Troopers that volunteered they
poured a slab they framed it put a roof
on it basic construction a a steel door
that was it and it's been there ever
since and we've shot there since as long
as I can remember to the point now where
you know we had U limited electricity
and uh yes so that's just that that's
just the way it was I want to say this
goes back to early early 90s if I can
remember maybe earlier than that maybe
late 80s but it's been
there quick followup Mr chairman real
quick uh very quick would are you going
to have simulators there as well and uh
you know robotics no I think no we don't
that that's not Incorporated in this I
mean it's basic you know there might be
some you know uh uh scenarios for moving
targets but it's it's it's very very
basic we're trying to get the utilities
in there number one it's a nice location
it's right off the highway it's worked
well for us it's functional if we get
utilities we get the water in there we
get we're not trying to overbuild this
so for the amount of Troopers that you
bring in at one time for training I
think this size is sufficient as long as
there's um the amenities running water
and a restroom connectivity so they can
have videos do some interactive training
because it's not just Firearms it's
handcuffing it's use of force it's
deescalation car stops uh things like
that that will happen right
there I have uh I I have one big big
pertinent question here I'm hoping I get
the right answer in both the uh our
worksheet and the governor's book we've
got a request for $2.3 million for this
gun range facility and in your
page page five says
1.59 million thank you for that question
I can speak to that
so that's an error in the PowerPoint but
what happened is originally that the 1.5
is what we put in for following that
after we met with public works and did
that initial assessment of the land and
what we wanted to build the electric and
the water um Public Works came back to
us and said with your request that can't
happen so then this is where the project
came in at it was the
2.3 ah that wasn't the answer I was
really looking for
I was hoping I was thinking that 1.5
million was looking pretty good for a
gun
range represent voyd thank you
commissioner Quin thank you for taking
my
question is it fair to say that this
facility with with the Troopers and
other police officers using the facility
that guns and Munitions are going to be
carried in and carried out that there's
not going to be a secure space on that
location where Munitions and weapons are
going to remain that's correct sir thank
you thank you Mr
representative alone thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question this is the only gun range
that's being used by state troopers
you represent
buer thank you Mr
chairman So currently the the gun range
as it is has just about a zero impact on
your
budget for upkeep or anything like that
versus now with the admin
of whatever it
was 2.3 million then it's going to
become a yearly addition to the budget
for upkeep electric internet service and
and and all the associated effects is it
also going to add headcount to the
training to hire a training person to to
maintain it or how we all
have coverage of security for who's
using it in its upgraded ability versus
now you know that that's a good question
I'll let I'll jump in before Amy can
touch on the um utilities but
essentially we maintain that now
ourselves with our own staff it won't
require hiring any additional training
Troopers I mean the Troopers that we
have that use that range today to do the
training will use a new range in the
future if if one gets approved um I
think Amy can speak to you know what the
charges might be the additional costs
whether it's electricity or sewer and
water I'm sure it'll be a well and
septic and um but Amy do you want to
speak to the I don't think it's
significant yeah so um I guess I would
speak more to your first question about
that it's that today it's there isn't
really a cost I would say that's um the
fac our facility team that I oversee is
at the range often dealing with molds
and addressing the generator that often
doesn't work so I would say that there
is a lot of funding going into just
maintaining something that is not so
functional today so we we put a great
deal of funding into it just to make
like take care of the mold over the last
year followup question at this point
could you tell me what your annual call
Star for upkeeping of this property at
um what we put into it to address the
mold last year I can't recall
um I can't recall the exact amount last
year I know that was the first time we
had to address kind of a larger quantity
like a larger issue with the
mold could I just add sir I think just
to put some context to this if you look
at the New Hampshire State Police their
responsibilities in the state if you
look at
how important training has been to keep
them you know as trained keep them
current if you look at the liability
that the state can face if someone's
improperly trained to look at just basic
a
functional place for them to go train
shoot clean their weapons get in and get
out of there and spend time and be able
to
um use a use a restroom if they need to
I think that in the long run it's
important for the state to have an
adequate training facility for the
largest Department in the state who have
immense responsibility I think it's long
overdue one followup yes uh I understand
that and I respect the uh fact that
we're looking for the safety but we just
heard we had a 28 Lane gun range and
Training Facility uh that they're
requesting funds for and uh I'm just
curious of how many different gun ranges
we need for law enforcement across the
state as we continually taking scarce
resources and trying to fund and keep it
as safe as we can so that our Public
Service people are properly trained
that that is that is absolutely a very
fair question a good question and I
think the best way for me to answer it
is if you look at the capacity of what
is at the police standards and training
and what their mission and goal is
they're training new recruits they're in
a controlled environment standing in a
range and shooting at targets down range
we don't have the ability there to move
we don't have the ability to shoot on
the move they don't have the ability
there to increase their blood pressure
to to run to to do different types of
scenarios and the Firearms Constructors
could speak better but by the when you
get to that range you're not just
standing there um shooting at uh
stationary targets there's more to it
and then when you add the handcuffing
the vehicle stops um adding stress to it
um so I think you know having the
ability to to do more I mean quite you
know the range at the police academy is
critical to training those new recruits
but this this offers more for the more
advanced um state trooper and police
officer
sir thank you seeing no further
questions we'd like to go ahead and move
please so this is on page Pages 9
through 11 and it is the um plate
production equipment modernization so
over the last 60 years the process of
manufacturing New Hampshire license
plates have remained virtually unchanged
today over 1.6 million registered
vehicles in the state um need for
modernization is more pressing than ever
license plates are a fundamental part of
a vehicle registration required through
RSA 261 subsection 40 and RSA 261
subsection 75 but the outdated equipment
used to produce them is becoming
increasingly difficult to maintain
currently New Hampshire's plates are
made from aluminum with Graphics applied
using a heat transfer process the
numbers and letters are raised through
cast iron stamping equipment that has
been in place and use since the
1960s maintaining this aging Machinery
presents significant
challenges replacement parts are no
longer readily available often requiring
Custom
Fabrication the specialized skills
needed to repair the service and service
the equipment are becoming harder to
find leading to increased downtime and
inefficiencies in production beyond the
equipment itself the current license
plate design has been in circulation for
over two decades without a structured
reissuance process many plates are
deteriorating losing their reflective
reflectivity and becoming difficult to
read the American Association of Motor
Vehicles administrators recommends
replacing plates every 10 years to
ensure visibility and compliance with
modern safety standards a transition to
a modernized production process would
allow for a more durable product that
retains its quality over
time upgrading licensed plate
manufacturing equipment would provide
several benefits first modern technology
would increase production capacity and
reduce downtime in ensuring a steady
supply of plates for New Hampshire
residents second enhanced security
features such as digital watermarks
improved
reflectivity and tamper resistant
elements would make it more difficult
for plates to be counterfeited or
altered and third the adoption of a more
sustainable manufacturing process would
reduce waste lower energy consumption
and align with environmentally
responsible practices and we're bringing
this in front of you today because our
concern is that the equipment will not
make it through the bium um to the next
Capital project so you can also see on
page 10 it's a um a few data points here
with um 600,000 plates produced each
year 91 different plate types and the
steps in the process is they're 12 um
some of these photos you can see um like
just on page nine you can see the um the
process those red hanging things from
the ceiling that's that's the oven so it
takes an hour for plates to go through
this oven and then the amount of gas
that it takes to run the oven um I went
to the Department of Corrections to
watch this process a couple weeks ago
and the equipment was down so it wasn't
able to actually watch it work um and it
had been down um for a week and a half
because they couldn't get a part um so
they have gone to other states to find
parts they've gone to eBay to find parts
and they were waiting for a part for a
machine called the Cincinnati and that's
the um machine that actually makes
plates for the legislature um but that
machine is almost a hundred years old um
so there are as far as like an inventory
they um we have about three months of
plates on hand so being down for a week
and a half is it's a long time and
that's not um that's not uncommon so
there are many times over the past
several months that a week and a half
has happened so it's just it's very
concerning and we wanted to put it on
your radar that we're not not confident
that this is going to make it to the
next
no questions move on to the lapses
please well I'm sorry representative
jurus thank you Mr chairman uh so we're
not am I clear with your with your
presentation we just don't know how long
or how much further we can
go with this equipment the stamping
machine I I think it's worse than that I
think we're bringing this in
because of the recent um the recent
amount of times that it's been down and
the fact that every year it gets a
little older and when they've got
equipment that they can't find
replacement pots for we just want to
make sure that you're well aware of the
current status of this equipment that's
so important quick followup where would
we
go would we would we subcontract it how
would we an emergency would we go to
different state and say can you make our
plates can you make a do a run of a th
5,000 plates you mean if we if we had to
like
have a plan B if this didn't go well
that's why I think what we want to do is
and I'll let Amy speak to it we're
making this proposal so that we can look
towards the most efficient and um cost
effective solution for the future of the
State of New Hampshire for these plates
having understanding that this equipment
is that old and in the you know recent
weeks it's been inoperable it's been
down samie do you want to I'm I can't
answer your question I'm not sure if you
can subc contract New Hampshire license
plates out to other states okay thank
you
fauler kazinski I'm sorry kazinski I
keep look I keep looking right through
you uh is the plan to keep the
Department of Corrections doing this job
or is someone else going to be doing
this if you get new Machinery I think I
think what we have discussed is if this
if funds are appropriated we go and look
out towards and deliver what is the best
and most efficient way to make these
plates whether it's inside the prisoner
outside follow up because I guess these
these guys aren't really going anywhere
it's kind of a captive audience but in
other words you're talking about maybe
um hiring new personnel and new
buildings and such to do this then
addition that's a great question we've
talked about that internally and I don't
I don't think you can get those the
answers to questions until you look and
see what this new equipment can do and
how much um how much labor is involved
in it how much can be automated I mean
right now we know it's a 12-step process
we know how many employees are there
from getting the aluminum rolled onto
the first machine getting the sheathing
overlaid taking the plate out there
handing it to someone else that's doing
the levers and stamping it that person
hands it to two other inmates that put
it on another machine and squeeze the
ink on it and if it's a green plate it's
green if it's red that goes through a
machine then it goes to the oven we
haven't even discussed the equipment
that does the stickers so when you look
at that that's also really so I guess I
can't answer that but I think that
that's why I think it's it would be in
everyone's best interest to look and see
like what is the best way to do this
moving
forward repres of Cl okay thank you Mr
chairman h a question on page 10 at the
top uh under modernization of plate
production equipment it says 600,000
plates produced per produced each year
is this two of the same plate for each
vehicle no that's 600 to Total 600,000
give a take roughly okay so follow up Mr
chairman so it's not 1.2 is this for
like motorcycles include motorcycles but
whatever that's everything that's that's
that's the best number they can give me
all in all right okay all right and uh
follow up so probably if for some reason
I don't want to get a debate here
because other committees have debated
this about if we went to just one plate
per motor vehicle would that obviously
number be cut right it would all right
okay you don't you can't give an
estimate how much you know I don't if
you thought about this question before
half of what you got right now you think
about half okay that's I just want to be
sure thank you Mr chairman thank you
Comm representative below thank you Mr
chairman and thanks Tak the question so
how'd you get to this 2.3 million figure
up I'm going to build a second question
question in which is were there
Alternatives so what are we looking at
for equipment thank you so we had
originally applied for um uh
Congressional delegated spending for
this project um so through that process
we had done we had put at some inquiries
to get a price so um in doing that I
used um the information we had gathered
when we did that
application to put this
forward
followup so I'm there just just confused
so I mean we talking about like you know
A Smith Press I mean just do you have
the equipment in mind that's basically
what I'm looking for and also were there
are alternatives too so there were
um I'm going off of what somebody else
had did for research so I'm sorry if I'm
I can only give you what I recall from
the application but there were um the
DNB had reached out to two vendors who
specialize in this
um equipment in this process and um they
got information from those two to
complete the application for this
funding which ultimately was denied but
um in that they were able to get an
estimate for what um with those vendors
recommend and what other states are
doing um so that's how we came up with
this number as the best
estimate thank
you representative fuler I'm going to
call you representative kazinski just to
be fair balance it out thank you Mr
chairman um not so much a question I
just wanted to
uh when we visited the women's prison I
think that one of the things that was
pointed out to us is that the uh giving
the inmates a useful job was important
as part of
their you know their Rehabilitation or
at least uh you know maintenance of
the of a prisoner population and
do you have a this with how many how
many people are actually involved in
this uh who work on the plates at the
prison and how how important is that as
part of their
General I I I would defer to
commissioner Hanks to you know comment
on how important it is to them but just
I was there I would say a month ago and
it was operational so I'm going to go
recall at least eight that I saw had
some function in it but again like I
said until you look to see what the new
equipment does you may not need it may
be one process as opposed to multiple
quick fall I point out when I first
learned the drive they replace the
plates every year because they would
rust out they're made out of steel so
soly the number of plates I used to
now okay we're getting pressed for time
would you like to move on to your your
uh laps approvals please yes so that is
page 10 of your
PowerPoint so the first one is the DMV
online
portal so that one was a project aimed
to enhance customer service by
leveraging technology to reduce weight
times at the DMB substations so several
initiatives here have been successfully
completed including expanding online
services to allow requests for duplicate
driver's licenses and non-d Driver IDs
as well as driver history records
additionally customers can now process
transactions on mobile devices and
automated Electric customer inquiry um
systems have been expanded to eing Kean
Milford and Newport DMV substations so
outstanding work here includes expanding
online services to accommodate request
for duplicate titles and registrations
dealer license renewals and inspection
station
renewals um so we are working with doit
for this in the anticipated timeline is
June of
2026 before you continue representative
Jack has a question uh given time is
short I don't see the uh a particular
need to go into the ones you want to
extend in detail but I do want to get to
the next page
if I understand the next page correctly
you want to lapse what is in house bill
25 is item
178 that is the fire academy new truck
1332 that project is complete and can
lapse yes that's federal funds though
yes and then the next one is 13 your
number
1333 is item 179 that's the criminal
records correct that's complete as well
and the previous one uh my record showed
time you said the previous one sir which
one is the previous your number 1331 the
fire academy
HVAC I I do not we don't have that being
I don't even see 13
31 it's on your your page 11 your page
is and maybe Mr Shay can help me with uh
their page says it's other funds on the
uh criminal records do we know what kind
of funds those
are my guess is it was Highway funds but
confirm I have to double
check we're gonna have to double check
on that sir okay okay but um Okay so
I've I've cross checked all the ones on
the previous page against what we have
and they're all there uh so we want to
laps number 178 and number 179 in the
capital
budget can you just give us a minute to
if you can if you can get us that
information by the 14th for follow up on
that that that would be fine we don't
won't need an answer for
today is that good represent
Jack thank you we just want to reconcile
the numbers to make sure they're lining
ours yeah the important thing is not to
leave one out if we needed it yeah
absolutely no we app appreciate your
your
assistance anything further for
representative
Boyd thank you Mr chairman for for
commissioner Quinn regarding hearkening
back to the to the gun range how many
how many acres is the gun range and
where is where is it located is it
located on Hazen drive or is it in oh no
it's right off Exit 23 in New Hampton
New Hampton you're up there New Hampton
yeah it's great if you so follow up Mr
chairman I want to come off the exit
said I make the right and the quick left
just
before no quick left is the dot shed you
go down like a tenth of a mile two10
from M take a left it's really it's
quiet Road it's quiet spot gotcha and
again circling back do you know how many
acres the property is I want to say
we've looked at
it it it goes I want to say less than
three give or
take less than three I think
it's you're in that ballpark that's fair
I don't mean put you on spot just trying
to Ballpark it it's narrow gotcha and I
think we can go beyond where the
existing building and Generator are so
when that comes
down okay thank you commissioner I
you representative
kazinski yeah also with the gun range in
with the license plates is
it possible to get a breakdown of how
you arrived at those
sir representative Newman final question
final question thank you this is a
little bit off topic but maybe not
sometime in the recent past I had
occasion to call do Mr lante to ask for
some assistance he directed me to Amy
Newberry she was exceptionally helpful
and uh you sent me a a letter email
thing whatever it was I thought you went
above and beyond to help me get directed
in the right direction thank
you seeing no further questions thank
you very much for your presentation
thank
you safy stands into a room to figure
they
ask a question have you guys thought
just want you know more than I do so
you
e
continuing on to the community college
thank you representative Mills Mark
Rubenstein Chancellor for the community
college system joined by Matt Moore
director of capital planning and Scott
Fields Chief Operating Officer for this
system and also uh executive director
Shannon
Reed please proceed you have a very very
short list I see we we we do we're
prepared to to discuss whatever you'd
like but uh in
the in our original submission we had
approximately $17.5 million of requests
uh some related to energy management
some related to uh critical maintenance
it and then some specific support for a
series of initiatives at Nashville
Community College in the governor's
budget uh We've specifically Reed
funding for uh relocation of a welding
program
you might know that we currently have a
satellite location in Rochester it's a
leas facility and that facility uh has
been purchased we're going to be
displaced at the end of
2025 so the objective for this
particular request is to be able to
relocate and expand the welding capacity
the capacity of the welding program from
Rochester to peas to continue to support
industry thank you and I take it we have
one other maybe request yeah uh as I
shared on slide two which included our
original request we had included 1.2
million in it related
Capital what following the governor's
budget we'd like to ask for additional
consideration for 800,000 specifically
for some it related Capital
expenses critical infrastructure to
support our technology needs across the
seven
colleges thank you
sir
um I oh I'm sorry I I just noticed now
this is this is your sixe plan on on the
second page yes I'm sorry I I probably
move more quickly to the uh Governor's
budget rather than the six-year plan
given the circumstances that we know
you're
facing thank you so we do have the
request for the 700,000 and a additional
request for 800,000 for
it
um like I said very short list can we
move on to your lap lapse extensions
then sir uh we we can if you'll allow
one additional comment on the uh Great
Bay Welding the request is 700 our
estimate for the project is actually 400
1.4 million we're anticipating absorbing
half of that expense uh but wanted to
request some support if it's available I
just want to add that as a detail thank
Moore yes we have a question
representative Brown yeah just I just
want to make sure I'm I'm straight here
because on the second page of their
request there before the six-year plan
that you mentioned they show 1.2 million
for 26 27 I thought there was some
discussion about 800,000 did I miss I
just want to make sure I'm not confused
on this we we we've narrowed the request
down we respectful of the pressures that
this committee and the legislature are
facing in this budget process so we
focused on some core priorities for
support follow up can you just give me a
little bit of a a little bit of detail
on what the
you thank you as you can see on slide
two we talk about our infrastructure and
its core Network
redundancy being able to provide
Wireless and routers and cyber security
tenants on the external side of it we've
implemented an EDR MDR kind of endpoint
management detection in the last 18
months to th external threats coming
into our system so we're looking at
bolstering that and also in terms of
again when we look at the W uh the
router components of our Network across
the the state we want to make sure we're
moving to when we go through refresh
those pieces of equipment we're getting
equipment that have solid technical
background that doesn't have gaps in its
security a back door if you will for
people to come in so we're looking to
make sure that we have top-notch Network
equipment and things of that nature in
place to safeguard our our
data follow
up thank you Mr chairman so in the
outline that you have here under the
detail so what what did you where's the
$400,000 that you paired down from this
1 point2 what's different from what you
outlined
in
listed we're likely to still make those
Investments we're simply asking less
from the state we'll have to look at our
own resources for the
balance okay thank
you so if I heard you correctly if if we
can't we can't fund the entire eight we
can't do something like 200,000 or 250
for it infrastructure you would welcome
that we will say thank you I I thought
so I just wanted to be sure thank
you representative bogert just for my
own clarification on
page no page number but as I turn over
to the first page so you're looking for
17.5
million there and then an additional
700,000 for the welding no no the the
the original request when we put in our
our six-year plan was for 17 the
governor's budget came back with no
funding the request for the project in
Rochester to move that welding lab from
Rochester to Portsmith was a late
arising uh initiative and we had
originally anticipated Federal support
for that that the funding is currently
held up and we are trying to facilitate
moving that program and expanding it
before we lose the lease in
Rochester so this is a new request
separate from anything else and we've
we've sort of stepped away from from
everything else that was
there follow up follow up because I'm
still slightly in the gray area here so
the 17.5 is off the table and
yes with the exception of the it the
800,000 for it okay so you have the it
is 800,000 you're requesting that was
originally denied so this is an
additional request yes outside and the
700,000 is an additional request correct
on the
side correct thank you the 700,000 has
been okayed in the governor's budget
okay that's what I'm trying to get to
thank
you Miss
Newman okay I'm I'm confused now um
Chancellor based on what you said that
moving
this oh from place what was whatever was
being moved did I understand you to say
that it was a it was going to be a
Federal grant so we originally had a
congressionally directed spending for
$700,000 to support moving the welding
lab that's currently in Rochester yeah
to Portsmith that funding is currently
tied up with other congressionally
directed spending and there's
uncertainty about whether those funds
will be
available follow up Ju Just to follow up
to clarify the
uncertainty I'm just it may or may not
come always a possibility and I I'll
I'll tell you if were to be released
timely so that we could use it I would
come right back here and tell you we we
can relinquish the
request okay
good follow up on the very first item on
these under the
um your your request in your six-year
plan on the 175 your very first item
project in priority order with that
energy management
system I just glanced at it quickly but
it's I mean I can understand why it was
Priority One
um
so if you don't have
that
then effects on heating ventilation and
lighting
are are and you can finish the sentence
thank you right right now we have
facilities across the state for our
seven
colleges each of those systems is manage
separately this basically
creates a smart environment where we can
manage remotely all of these things
optimize the energy use on these pieces
of equipment but also help us identify
where we've got a water leak where we've
got a boiler that's running too hot
things that will tend to degrade that
equipment more rapidly so it's a
combination of more efficient coste
effective energy management but also
should extend the life of these uh
pieces of equipment should also mitigate
some of the risks we face when pipes
break when we have flooding because
those things go undetected at a location
that's not not physically staffed at the
time it occurs thank you you're
welcome thank you any further
questions representative kazinski thank
you um so you said the total to move
from Rochester to peas is one .4
million
what so Ju Just I'm trying to so this is
going from a leas building to you're
building a new building no we have a
facility at peas we've got to refit the
space currently there are 14 welding
booths in the facility in Rochester
we're planning to expand that to 18
we'll run multiple cohorts through that
there are some additional areas where
equipment is used that's complimentary
to welding so the equipment but also the
ventilation that goes with that for
safety uh to ensure that that students
and and faculty who are participating in
those programs are are kept
healthy okay thank you you're
welcome seeing no further questions
let's move on to your laps
extensions thank you Mr
chair so in the laws of 23 U
1131 um
111 for critical maintenance we're
asking that that be um
Extended
um because we've um spent encumbered uh
2,486
275 uh is unspent um I'm sorry the 938
725 has been spent and encumbered
uh leaving it available to
2486 but um I have consultants in the
design phase and contracts being uh
bidding um right now to do this work as
it um as the same for the next um for
the last two items okay the next
appropriation uh for the um respiratory
therapy program laws of 23
1131 um
163 um that is um we started the design
phase but do you want to speak if if I
may if I interrupt May interrupt you sir
I think um representative Jack is
handling this I've um if he has a
question otherwise we're we're fine with
with the lapses and if we notice your
bottom line says funds to lapse from
completed projects is none correct we're
actually we're not that concerned with
how projects are going if they're being
extended okay so in the interest of time
I've cross checked your four that you to
extend I have two uh other ones we have
uh from
2019 NCC engineering technology
renovation that's one of the completed
yes so that should lapse with zero yep
and then there's another one that was
appropriated in 2021 section
14 uh for critical maintenance and that
one is completely all right
good thank you see we can we could
sometimes speed things up here thank uh
and and that's it that that we have
unless there's any further questions for
Community
College seeing none gentlemen thank you
very much for your presentation thank
you all for your time we appreciate your
support
next up we have the fish and game
department
I I don't know but the question I want
to ask you is yes he does the short
corrected it is it's in
got good afternoon thank you chairman
and committee members I'm Stephanie Simi
I'm the executive director for New
Hampshire fishing game and I have with
me our business division Chief Cath
leonti and our Inland Fishery Chief
Diane
Timmons um as you are aware I'm new to
this seat so I wasn't necessarily here
when we built this budget but uh that's
why I'm bringing the power horses here
and uh we'll walk through it a little
bit and feel free to ask any questions
or however the chairman would like to
proceed with this welcome to New
Hampshire thank you very much I'm very
excited to be
here so we did hand out some documents
um you will see our original ask was the
uh document that has the very fine print
and then as you can see uh the capital
uh the governor's budget the capital uh
that she appropriated or at least
identified in her budget is slightly
different than what we originally asked
for uh you'll see four projects there
four things that we had asked for
initially which was Hatchery Predator
control uh we asked to replace a 50 foot
25ton trailer we asked for Inland
Fisheries equipment and we also
requested replacement of a John Deere
backhoe what is in the governor's budget
is the Hatchery Predator control the
replacement of the 50-foot trailer and
the Inland Fisheries equipment but not
the backhoe um I would like to if
there's an opportunity I would like to
request reconsideration of the backo
because it's much needed however I'm not
sure of the process here so we can get
to that in a little later um I will say
that uh the allocations that you will
see that we asked for initially are
lower than what was uh put in the
governor's budget and and that's because
we did have some changes along the way
when the first capital uh request was
put in for the Hatchery Predator control
um there were some little nuances that
we hadn't accounted for and that's why
there's a difference and she has
obviously uh addressed that and then
also in the Inland Fisheries equipment
uh we had not received a formal quote
yet for some of the generator uh work or
generators that we needed and
subsequently uh we spoke with was a Das
I think that identified that hey this is
the quote that we received it was
considerably more so you'll see that
that is a change in that amount as
well I notice these are not General
funds these are all fish from the fish
and game fund is that correct that is
correct uh and I will defer to Mr Shay
to answer your question on how we can
address that backo request okay thank
you it would really depend on how
healthy the fishing game fund is to
handle the debt service related to to
that um project or that piece of
equipment so I
think would be the department would need
to make sure they were okay with the
health of the fund to take on that debt
service and I know there's been some
questions about the fund and its Health
going
forward yes thank you very much I
appreciate that do you want to add
anything to that please I do not okay um
I'm happy to answer any other questions
relevant to the original request and to
the
governor's representative voy thank you
Mr chairman and thank you ladies for
taking my question how old is the back
home it is actually I have that I think
it's
almost 50 let me find out where it is
here it is it's over 27 it's 27 years
old and new parts are discontinued we
have tried to repair it through various
options we even tried to find an old one
as a surplus we w
in other words you were looking for
MacGyver to fix it is that what you're
saying yes yes we couldn't find MacGyver
couldn't find MacGyver okay yes but the
option too is if we can replace it with
a um a same brand we could potentially
keep this some of the parts might be
transferable to a newer unit not all
obviously because that's what we're
running into but yes what what is the
cost of this the back new request yes
it's
350,000 that sounds about that sounds
about right Mr chairman follow up
not not my size backles I I get that I
get that follow up thank you Mr chairman
the um Hatchery predator predator
control is this for the Hatchery down in
Nasher or is that for all the for all
the hatcheries in in the in the state
it's actually was originally for Milford
and I will let I will let our chief of
Inland fishery speak to
that yes hi so it was this quote is for
Milford specifically okay we are looking
at um our other facilities as well and
obviously with the new
modernization of new Hampton that will
be steel structured buildings okay one
last followup I just it's it's a
curiosity question how how robust has
the Hatchery been over the last last
couple of years and are are fishermen
benefiting from the the stocks being
replenished in our in our streams and
Brooks oh 100% yes so um I can tell you
that our recre ational angling
is predominantly provided through
stocking and it brings 1.4 billion to
our economy so it's tremendous angling
is one of the favorite pastimes of many
folks and those folks in state as well
as out of state and Milford Hatchery is
one of our it is the dominant hatchery
in the southern part of the state so
excellent thank thank you for your work
I appreciate it thank you Mr chairman
representative Jack thank you Mr
chairman am I correct that the hatchery
in ASA that was just referenced is
actually a federal facility New Hampton
is our is our state facility NASA is a
federal Hatchery that's different so
Milford is a Milford is our state
facility South that provides our
stocking in New Hampshire NASA does um
different products that are not state
funded thank you m you're welcome any
further questions representative Newman
yes Ju Just for my
understanding this page shows the the
back ho for 350 but in the book it's
275 this is obviously more current the
more expensive price
okay yes that's
correct inflation okay
yes so that's the figure working with
350 not
questions saying none ladies thank thank
you very much for your presentation hold
on yeah so I've crosschecked your laps
extensions with Hospital 25 and they all
look fine so thank you very much unless
there's any question about it we'll
we'll continue those are there any
questions on our current Appropriations
for Capital funding I think
not thank you very much I'm sorry
representative bogert okay I must have a
blind
spot um an earlier question was on the
the uh funding for the back ho because
you're asking that to be an addition
to uh and it was said what the fishing
game funding source or whatever bonding
ability or whatever uh but the answer
never came out is do you have the
ability to cover it and that was the
Crux of the whole
question that would be very dependent
upon on how what the re the end result
of this budget process will be once we
get to May and
June yes
followup can you scratch below the
surface of that statement a little bit
because that was as vague as we we our
budget our agency budget request had an
amount of General funds that were a
Target amount by the governor's office
so we put in that amount of General
funds going through the governor's phase
of the budget those General funds were
removed putting
the amount that we were requesting onto
the unrestricted fishing game fund which
leaves us not with a healthy balance at
the end of the current bium we're going
into so until those issues are resolved
we are really not sure what the health
of the fishing game will be at the end
bium thank
you
yeah see no further
questions okay something well I was just
going to add that we are currently
working with house division 2 on uh this
measure about the balance and where we
might be able to increase some of our
fees or our our registrations or other
avenues for revenu to offset that so as
Kathy clearly identified that once we
get through that process we'll have a
better standing on where we can uh be
Bond thank you thank you very much thank
time the Human Services
get
e
all right next up on our list is
Department of Health and Human Services
or the capital budget presentation
welcome to public
you we did provide a slide deck for you
to walk through um granted that we only
have currently two items in hb25 we
thought you might be interested in um
other items that the agency uh had on
their list as well as uh projects in
Flight if you will and where those
stand so
if ready to
go um the very first page I think is
consistent with what you have in your uh
handout there in terms of our Medicaid
Enterprise modular strategy in terms of
the total funds that we're looking at
there 33 million project and about 3
million in 3 milon 375 in general funds
and the rest is a match with our federal
funds so that's a 9010 match and then
our modernizing the eligibility Services
that's a 656 th000 on the general fund
with a match of about 1.2 million um
from the federal government so those two
together um are a total for current uh
requests that are in
hb25 um I've asked my chief of
operations Dave weers who's sitting here
with me to walk you through a little bit
about what is the Medicaid Enterprise uh
strategy um what is that compris of it's
a rather large project it's a 10-year
project we're halfway through the year
some of you that have been on this
committee before probably remember us
asking about this five years ago so I'd
like Dave to give you a brief update on
thank you um chair and members of the
committee my name is David weeders Chief
Operating Officer for the record for
DHHS so the Medicaid Enterprise modular
strategy is a strategy following Center
for Medicaid and Medicare
Services um efforts for the the country
and what we did is we working with um
CMS as well as looking at other state
Solutions and some of our Professional
Services providers came up with a
strategic plan on how we could modularly
replace the components of the current um
Legacy system that is monolithic and
what that really means is we have a
really big system that does claims
processing it manages third-party
liability insurance um monitoring as
well as provider management call center
management and fiscal functions as well
as data analytics and a number of other
things but that having one vendor to do
all that work they subcontracted it out
sort of locked us in for a while and we
looked at an opportunity to modularly
replace it using cms's strategy that
allows us to get best-in-class Solutions
as well as create a more competitive
Marketplace for
procurement and so we as the
commissioner indicated we're in uh year
five of a 10-year plan we have other
capital projects that we'll highlight at
the end of this slide deck that was
really helping us get started with this
this 33 million and and 33 and 3/4
million uh dollar Capital effort is to
support the implementation of the third
party liability U module which is really
gold at ensuring that Medicaid is the
last payer so if the if the claimant has
uh commercial insurance or has other
insurance that can pay for the claim
that third party liability helps us
identify those through verifications and
matching and reclaim those funds so that
we don't
inadvertently pay a
claim and that should have been paid by
a different um insurance provider the
other solution is a call center
management and so the the key strategy
on the call center component is that
right now when you call the Department
of Health and Human Services for many of
its programs 70 80 plus programs you
have different call centers managing
those phone calls I don't know if any of
you have ever called to a call center
only to be dumped to another call center
to be dumped to another call center to
never actually get your answered the
goal here is to have a centralized
solution so you can call one number that
can triage have access to a knowledge
base and a Care Management tool so that
they can provide you the answers that
you need in real time and if they can't
escalate you to the right person at a
tier 2 level to resolve your issue or
your request the third component or
module is the Care Management or member
management um module
and what that one is meant to do for a
Medicaid Enterprise is to take multiple
case management systems that we have
across our department and create that
overarching view following privacy and
security rule um following all of our
state and federal laws but in order to
ensure that we can pull that together
and not do duplicative services for
individuals but also make sure that they
get services that they need in a timely
manner currently we have multiple system
doing this work so in multiple call
centers so you call a call center they
use their Care Management tool only to
find out that you need a service from
public health to be moved to another
another call center and another tool so
this really is gold at bringing
efficiency to the department and moving
us forward for the mees strategy I just
want to clarify that Dave's talking
about different call centers we don't T
typically have large call centers like
we have people maybe people that are
call the call center right so we have
designated lines for people to call in
with staff Manning those so I don't want
you to think that we've got five
desparate uh call centers we have
probably eight different numbers that
people are calling into to take this
money to be able to streamline and
leverage that money to benefit all of
the systems across the department so the
investment goes just beyond the obvious
of the of the Medicaid calling in system
I just want to make that
clear thank you for the
clarification and so if there's no
questions on that one I'll move to the
next slide oh sorry representative
Boyd thank you Mr chairman and Mr
weeders and commissioner thank you very
much for taking my
question this is kind of new to me
so work with me with the question that
I'm about to ask you because I don't
know how it fits into the grand scheme
of things but I know that in this state
we have three Medicaid providers of Mer
Health well sensed in centine that that
provide Medicaid services to to people
that that qualify for Medicaid services
obviously they have the they have call
centers as well and they rely upon the
data that they get from the state how
does their ability to service those
clients uh synergize with with this
particular project and are they
assisting the state in any way to make
sure that the data that's being used is
is the correct data whether it be from
from a Care Management perspective or
just having having a simple claim being
processed
want me
to certainly um so there's a number of
things that are synergized there so this
is a component of our call centers but
we we partner with a health caras
wellsense and New Hampshire Healthy
Families on a regular basis and these
Solutions are what they actually use so
they use our mismis our Medicaid
management information system for claims
processing and they use our provider
management component of that which are
some of the modules that we're actually
moving forward forward with the original
capital what they how they would
interact with the third party liability
is we we have an obligation if they
don't catch it in their solution that we
have an obligation to have our own um
third party liability insurance um
contract um to ensure that we are doing
that one extra step of auditing and
ensuring that the payments are going to
the right processing I would say over
the last several years um the three mcos
that we partner with have actually
addressed a lot of that and we're not
anticipating um a lot of recoveries but
we are anticipating being compliant with
cms's regulations and requirements is to
have that contract in place and it helps
us reinforce the importance of that TPL
or third party liability the go ahead no
go go ahead and then the the the call
center component uh is what we're doing
with the call center and the Care
Management is is broader than just the
Medicare so one of the things that CMS
has allowed us to do is leverage
Medicaid um Federal funding for Medicaid
enhancements in this Enterprise strategy
that could be leveraged across our
department and build that Foundation
from which we don't have um all the
funding or general funds to implement
the a call center solution which results
in those teams of of individuals that
the commissioner was referring to trying
to handle those phone calls as best that
they can this is building this the
infrastructure for us to do that the the
mco's call centers would be that tier
two where they initially might call us
and then we'd find that they need to go
to their their MCO we would help them
find their which MCO that they would go
to and they could choose and go to the
mcos from there so we would be able to
provide that information so that they
could choose the which call center to go
from from that point um so that's I
would say these three modules aren't as
tied to the MCO component but other
components of the mees strategy like
provider management and claims
management claims processing really are
and that's where your question sort of
hits home in terms of how do we ensure
that we have a good provider management
solution so when our MCL are working
with their providers to onboard them
into our system for claims processing
that we streamline that and build an
efficient way for them to be able to do
that
work and I just want to clarify although
we partner we contract obviously with
those mcos right so this is our system
that all of our providers are required
to use so it's it's mcos and Beyond um
for claims processing and others other
things Mr CH follow up I'm not surprised
So ba based on based on that with the
three with the three
mcos you've coordinated with the three
the three mcos and the mcos have for the
lack of a better word they've financed
their side of their their side of the
system so that they it complements
what's being done on on the state side
the theyve point I'm getting at is the
mcos have paid their fair share and and
I'm not saying that taxpayer money isn't
being used but they've paid their fair
share to ensure that that that
synchronization is in place so that that
when they have to communicate with the
state one system's talking with the
other system and vice versa if that
makes sense yes okay yes I mean the the
idea is we don't want to have duplicity
right I mean the whole the whole point
is to have one system that works well
together right I just follow I I just I
with this particular
process families that that that are
participating with an MCO are being
steered to the MCO and not taxing uh
somebody at at Department of Health and
Human Services uh
unneeded so that they're being gated
correctly to where they need to go yes
okay I appreciate the the answers thank
you thank you Mr
chairman okay continue thank you so on
the next slide where it indicates
modernized eligibility services so this
is our our integrated eligibility and
enrollment system for snap tanif and
Medicaid or food stamps um cash
assistance and Medicaid insurance as
well as the child care um system uses
that and in addition that system last
year um supports the developmental
disabilities um and the area agency
supporting that that that population
within our state
and so this specific Capital project is
really focused at enhancing the
self-service component which we call New
Hampshire easy um so New Hampshire easy
is a website that both providers as well
as um clients can go to and find a
wealth of information on how they can
apply for these Services however it has
been indicated in many cases that it's
not very um it's more it's not as
intuitive to manage and it's not put in
a in a current format so most people
today are expecting to be able to go to
a website fill in information click
submit and go forward our website has a
number of PDF forms that they have to
fill out and then scan and then submit
them as part of the application our goal
is to try to streamline some of those
services and make it more self-service
oriented which in in turn will reduce
the redeterminations and the delays for
services as well as um um errors in
terms of building in the scanned
documents that you can't read the
information that was written on them
having to call them back and get that
information this this allows for an
improved customer experience but it also
allows for better verification so we're
obligated to verify all the information
of an individual applying for these
services having it being an automated
system where it has error checking to
ensure that we get the accurate
information the first time allows us to
check against those verification
databases to ensure that we have the
right person the right income
information the right um employment
information and then be able to make
that determination and move it
forward the the last part of this of the
goals is to be able to utilize um what I
would consider old technology but it's
current technology for healthcare is
using SMS texting to be able to meet a a
client where they're at so we would be
using text and email in addition to the
phone and and mail office offerings I
mean we we will always have individuals
that will choose to have a paper um
application or choose to have access to
that kind of paper U communication
through their through their post office
but we want to also realize that a lot
of our population do have cell phones
that could use that to actually apply
take pictures of their driver's license
take pictures of their of their
documents and upload them in real time
representative
Boyd thank you Mr chairman question do
has has the has Health and Human
Services as a department um as it
relates to text messaging has there been
any security concerns as it relates to
the participant in an employee uh having
that face-to-face
interaction um certainly there's always
opportunities to employ good security
practices when you use new digital
Solutions the way we would use text
messaging is similar to the way
hospitals would use it where we would
text them a link to the portal go log
into New Hampshire easy so you can see
the documents that you need to upload
and always redirecting them to a site
that is a secure site to maintain the
communication of protected health
information or personally identifiable
information but it does allow us to in
real time say hey you have a notice
waiting for you in New Hampshire easy if
you're looking for your determination on
your application please click this link
so that that was the goal of utilizing
SMS U we would never we would also have
the similar disclosures as you would see
in other commercial environments where
it says we're not going to ask you for
your password or date of birth or any of
your Social Security or other personally
identifiable information via text or
email we're always going to ask you to
submit that through our secure New
Hampshire easy website thank
you and if I could just just on this
piece um the goal is to make New
Hampshire easy easy right we often get
the feedback that New Hampshire easy
isn't easy U part of that is this is um
sort of a service that hasn't been as
automated as some of our other areas of
the department so we are relyant upon
staff which I don't have a lot of and I
have a lot of vacancies so the more
vacancies I have the more time it takes
for people to get their answers on
determinations for eligibility so if we
can even just automating this and this
this part of it here is going to make a
big difference in our efficiency and
speeds and getting people the services
quicker and then if I could I'm sorry go
right if I could have one more thing one
of the things that we did notice because
we do submit our Capital budgets about
um 12 months in advance we were able to
work with our our federal partners and
we anticipate being able to reduce the
general fund impact to just below
$600,000 so that basically the current
breakdown is 35% general fund Federal
65% we're anticipating being able to
bring that to 32% General and then 68%
Federal we don't have that approved yet
because we can't get approval until we
go we get the funding but that is where
we are getting signals as to our our
cost allocation
breakdown Mr Shay are you okay set with
that I think what I just heard is it
would they need to be appropriate ated
the funds first and then they would be
able to get a different cost allocation
but correct me if I'm
wrong you're not wrong it's it but
that's how all of our Capital submittals
are so if if the if the committee was
looking at this in terms of general fund
impacts we we anticipate being able to
reduce that general fund impact for this
Con this Capital project by just a
little over
$56,000 and that would lapse at the end
of the project if if the full amount was
appropriated yes it would it would lapse
at the end of the project project right
so you wouldn't make any change at this
time because they don't know for sure
that the federal government will give
them the the ratio that they're asking
for thank you but we just wanted to
share that that was what we were
pursuing that's what we'd like to hear
representative Jack uh thank you some
years ago we were coping with the
situation where the federal government
said your systems aren't compliant with
our requirements and we're within an
inch of finding you or if I'm
paraphrasing are we out of that woods
that the government happy we're always
in the woods feels
like this isn't Disneyland I think
that's a complex question however um we
have a number of systems but there are
there was one um capital budget that you
may be referring to representative Jack
U which was the electronic visit
verification project that we had a
capital project for we we have been we
have are currently compliant with the
Home Health Care component of the
electronic phys verification system and
we are no longer paying fines to the
federal government for those um we are
not entirely complete with that project
so we are continuing that project to add
the area agencies for developmental
disabilities however that was not where
we were
non-compliant representative
alom thank you very much Mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question so 90%
of the cost is in federal hands what are
you hearing from the federal government
about
that money because we're hearing a lot
of things about what's going on and so
funding I don't I'll let I'll let Nathan
um answer specifically but in terms of
our it capital costs that's not money
that is being looked at right now or
targeted so it's different than some of
the money that we might Federal money
that REM receipt for public health or
for services but for some of this
infrastructure and technology part of
this side of things it's still at 90% we
haven't I haven't had any indication
that that's at risk sounds more secure
right as long as he's not back there
dancing around behind me I got that
right you got you got thumbs up from
right further questions none see none
proceed
please okay so the next so we've cover
we've covered your two approved items in
the governor's budget that is correct Mr
chair
okay so um I'm going to go through these
at a real high level and then if you
have any questions specifically about
these these um capital projects that are
not included in the current Governor's
hb25 submitt um at the high level the
Glen Cliff home security system at of
$1.3 million in general funds no federal
funds or other funds that's really to
complete this security system um upgrade
for the Glen Cliff home environment
including Wireless internet throughout
the the campus so that um the clinicians
can provide care no matter where they
are on the campus um as well as video
surveillance for different rooms and
ensuring that we are constantly inv
visible to our patient our our um
residents at the Glen Cliff home the the
Aging disability Resource Center or adrc
information referral system uh a million
dollars General funds and million doll
federal funds is a total of $2 million
it's 50% federally funded through
CMS that that solution is to provide um
information referral for about four um
4,000 agencies using the system
providing Services um to the agent
community in our in our
state the multilanguage support for
client notices in in terms of federal
regulations we're all oated to translate
our information into um other languages
specifically languages of populations
higher than a certain percentage in our
state um Spanish is one of the
predominant ones that we're obligated to
translate into so we we're trying to
become compliant with our eligibility
system to ensure that we are translating
those notices into Spanish and other
languages that are prevalent in our
state and that that one is u 90%
federally funded at a total of 1.2
million in change and then the the
fourth one here is document management
and retention so this one didn't make it
to our top of the list however it's
super important in terms of efficiency
for our state and our department where
we have lots of data records that have
different record retention periods in
each individual that works for public
service is obligated to manage their
records
appropriately and Destroy them when they
when the retention period is over this
this solution automates that so that
emails Word documents reports all those
thing all those items of record get
assigned a record retention schedule and
automatically destroys it at the end of
the retention period and manages it
effectively to be compliant with with
record retention policy it is a a fairly
common thing in in government to have
these type of solutions to ensure that
we're not unnecessarily keeping records
around for
decades in some cases longer as well as
document management allows us to put
into a database a structure where we can
retrieve information at a rapid pace so
that when someone asks us where was that
where was that application that was
submitted on February 10th
2021 by David weeders that we can go
into the system and pull that up rapidly
and show that it's still there because
it's a record retention of 7 years and
so it hasn't expired and that's why we
still have the record that solution is
um estimated at or scheduled to be at
1.45 million and it's 50% General funds
and the reason why it's not a larger
Federal fund match is it's not just
Medicaid it would be supporting the
entire department that has M multitude
of federal funding um
participation then the the last to the
DHHS elevator Replacements there are a
total of I think eight elevators if I
remember correct maybe I got the number
wrong um they're they're over at our New
Hampshire hospital and seven my apology
seven elevators that are essentially end
of life end of replacement that are
failing um at at different rates so the
New Hampshire hospital always has at
least one or two elevators not working
at any given time which results in
patients having to be rerouted through
different units in some cases as well as
um manually having individuals carry
boxes and other materials up and
downstairs whereas at Glen Cliff home
when the the elevator that is is at that
location fails they actually have to use
stairs for any transport and so not
replacing those and deferring
maintenance on those does run the risk
of us not having the ability to
transport patients and residents through
our 24/7 facilities and it actually
incurs an efficiency impact to our our
productivity and services in those
locations I know I know that there are
other elevators throughout the state as
well that were on I think a different
Department's
um
submitt so
that that one is estimated three three
just under 3 and a. half million 3.45
million it's all General funds because
of the Departments the the divisions
that it supports and do not qualify for
for federal fund Federal funding and
then the last one here is the Glencliff
home fuel system upgrade and so in in
this case the system is not only end of
life end of replacement but there there
really just aren't any parts we've
scavenged parts from other communities
um that had those parts to try to get
repaired it is located in a a part of
the the the campus that actually lends
itself to have high risk of it being U
damaged and could result if we don't
repair it at some point in time in
violations where the dep dep Department
of Environmental Services will require
us to replace it in order to continue
functioning um so that that solution is
is estimated $1.2 million and the the
reason why the large amount is that we
would have to not only relocate the tank
but also ensure that all inspect
everything on the campus ensure that the
fuel system can be delivered properly so
it's a lot of um construction work to
ensure that it's done properly if you
have any questions on any of those um we
do have Todd here for Glen cliff and we
have um Ernie here for some of the the
it systems representative Newman please
yes uh could I ask you about the Glen
Cliffe fuel system uh what is the fuel
system I mean what what type of what
does it do to heat because I was there a
few years ago when I saw I thought it
looked pretty new it was a biomass
system with okay go ahead hello uh Todd
Bickford home executive director um you
were you went for a tour of the bi Mass
plant which is our Steam and Heat this
is basically a gas pump like if you go
to a gas station it's in our grounds
area but it's located in the middle of a
um busy parking lot so cars go around it
and because of its location um there's
an overhead power line to it that's been
knocked down a couple of times by trucks
because it lwh hangs and the real
concern is that it's 28 years old and
Dees has inspected it the last three
years but has said you're only passing
because you're grandfathered um the tank
itself is not double walled like it's
supposed to be the um spill concrete pad
around the the the pump itself is too
small um for modern code so um if we fix
it again quote unquote we have to
replace it um and it is so aged I mean
literally the last part we got like two
years ago was off eBay um so it it's gas
oh the gas is we maintain our own Fleet
we have uh four handicap vans for um
transport residents to medical
appointments we have a uh resident bus
to take residen out for activities and
fun things uh then we maintain our own
plowing Fleet because we maintain um two
and a half you been the campus so we do
all our own plowing uh we have a a
number of um four um off-road vehicles
for also doing plowing and things like
that follow quick followup so the
biomass Heats heats water that makes
steam but the steam is not heating the
building totally so this is basically
we're just talking about I'm sorry I
think it's my mistake you're okay
clarify we're basically just talking
about a gas pump gas pump if you went to
the gas gas vehicles gas pump for your G
not building
Sor there we
go that's great yeah I think the pieces
here they're selfs staining facility
campus right so everything is on there
so the gas that Supply is the supplies
to all of the work that needs to get
done and separate from the heat so they
could run to the gas station a million
own representative
kazinski well we're talking about that
how how big of a tank is
this I believe it is a 700 gallon
tank that's $1.2
million the reason it's uh so expensive
is not only do we need to replace it but
we need to move it and that involves
moving power lines moving the tank
bringing it up to code um doing some
grading work um those type of things so
it's it's a significant
project okay thank
you representative
Boyd thank you Mr
chairman can't begin to tell you how
many times I've driven past Glen cliff
on my way to Woodsville and
how sitting in the shadows of Mount
musaki how remote it is but I also
recognize that from a security
perspective it's challenging because
it's just you out in the middle of
nowhere there my question is how often
do you get hikers that use the
Appalachian
Trail frequent frequenting the campus
creating unnecessary concern for for the
guest at Glen cff uh thank you for the
question u i don't have specific numbers
but um having been there for 24 years I
can tell you it's easily a dozen to 15
times a year it actually just happened
um about 6 weeks ago um on an off shift
and two hikers um made it all the way
into a resident area until a nurse asked
some and they were just looking to use a
phone but uh in the bathroom uh but it
did speak to your point of we're in the
middle of of the woods and on appalation
trail so we get hikers quite frequently
and other people that that are looking
for directions okay thank you appreciate
represent Newman
yes the the site visit was it was pretty
it was really interesting um and I just
asked and I usually ask this every time
Glen Cliffe comes up so when you have to
have any repairs done we talked several
years ago about people who have to come
up to do contract work or that are
looking to do a bid they make a site
visit so they know what they're dealing
with and where they're dealing with so
they can give you a complete um
bid that that is correct we always
strongly um advocate for Public Works to
hold an a mandatory on-site um bid
process for that exact reason because in
in projects in the past we've run into
where uh you know bids come in and then
they're awarded and then the company's
like whoa we didn't realize you were an
hour and a half outside of conquer um
they see the state of New Hampshire and
conquer any further questions
uh before we get into your uh lap system
I've I've got a one quick one and you
don't have to get it to me right away
but if you know going back to your
elevator
project if you could get us the cost
please
just replacing the Blen Cliffe elevator
just approximately sure get back to us
and then representative Jack will go
through the uh
uh lapse items with you because he's
he's got his own system and it works
well and goes
swiftly you don't know about this case
you're up I already delivered for you I
already delivered for you representative
Swift you're up all right well I have a
good deal many more laps extensions than
you have on your
sheet okay and I'm I'm having difficulty
matching them up
so let me go from the oldest one which
is 2011 repl platform op option
application and that's not mentioned in
this year's House Bill
25 so is that project
okay the next one is from 2013 new
heights incremental modernization again
um if you bear with me give me one
moment I need to pull up a spreadsheet I
know what you're pulling from I I'm
pulling from the previous year's House
Bill 25 what was appropriated or lapse
extended in that
budget and comparing it to what is laps
extended in this
budget and 2013 Roman 7e New Heights
incremental
monitorization uh is not extended in
this budget and was extended Ed in the
previous
budget and that is correct as that
project is also complete most most of
these probably will be but we found over
the years we don't want to miss one that
that you may have missed so we'll right
the problem being they have nine items
on their list and I have about
25 so we're going to have
to um from 2015 Roman 7 L New Hampshire
sorry I'm right yeah I just need to give
Dave a minute to look some of that up
because we have a couple of projects
happening at New Hampshire hospital so
I'd need to know specifically which
L and I apologize to the rest of the
committee but there's I mean we're we're
talking about over half a page
of items here so and it doesn't match up
well with what they
money so you're on House Bill 25 from
well previous year the the original
appropriation is from
2015 uh Romans and the references Roman
7 letter L New Hampshire hospital
renovation of I'll make a suggestion can
we go over the ones that you know of
that you want to have approved and Marty
you can get with them and give them your
list and they can either come back or or
get you that information for Friday's
meeting all right if you're agreeable
that would be great because it allow
wrap up committee we can go through this
list if you want to do that just just
give them that list that you've got yeah
if you provided to us I don't know if we
have access to those spreadsheets to get
you the accurate information sitting
right here I think that's what Dave is
trying to dig for but if you give them
that to us we can then fill it in and
get it back to you to get it to the
committee can you send them the thing I
sent you okay
great we'll get that back to you we can
how how would it be if uh Mr Shay sends
you this document that I'm working from
which he has and then honor before the
day for the lapse extension subcommittee
we work through it yeah we'll as soon as
Chris gets that we'll get it filled out
okay are we all happy with that solution
yeah thank wonderful this is one that
just didn't work in real
time sometimes it
does any further
questions any concerns seeing none thank
you very much for your
presentation thank you thank
you for the committee all we need to
know is that our
next meeting for the second half of
these presentations will be next Monday
10:00